[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good afternoon what's going on
three-hour joint yesterday three-hour
drink was likely today
what's going on around eagles fan 76
your first let me shout out novice today
he'll be the first up in here almost
every sunday
much love to you brother yes i'm looking
forward to
the e3 digital if it you know whatever
format they willing to offer it we'll
see how
it goes down but um yeah
what's up akw what's up spider what's
going on wandering dutch the legendary
wandering dutch mix up midweek
podcast my guy the viking what's up
what i'm saying what's going on yeah
just waiting for the realms to uh to
pull up you know um like i said long
night
attic should be rested i don't have
nothing out of it he did not he
had to work so he's gonna do the three
hours
[Music]
the dripping issue or whatever and i
can't play through that kingdom away so
those doubts
so yeah man the lord should be uh
hopefully pulling up soon as the
king earlier getting ready and then
eric's the legend
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the snapple and making it
flammable this is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh i
guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beating
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal um
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but
[Music]
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tiller uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get to blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we with
messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
um
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog's thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
[Music]
i ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again hear you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing
but that's all a part of me being
accountable and they say i'm better than
money because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal um
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
and turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for attic
if i can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you gonna be single player
like siren you gonna get tossed in the
bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be meto
i know it's my destiny worked a cognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you're sweating away something
but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that jew king
david still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it and
nothing is cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
is doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
oh damn
[Laughter]
and we are live welcome to the iron lord
podcast and the lords of gaming.net
episode number 196 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got digital e3
ps5 dual sense drift e3 deciding the
fate of anthem
and kingdom hearts to pc to discuss so
we're going to get right into it
i want to introduce the lord whom the
ilp is truly honored to call a friend
and respected ally to the round table
knowing this law symbolized the essence
of high production values and
professionalism
but his uniquely created platform by
combining the fitness
gaming and fashion communities
introducing the co-founder and director
of the eric's game youtube channel
video games and a panelist for the dcp
side quest the most electrifying beard
in the game
and the original iron lord of fitness
live from london and making his annual
return
into the realm of the lords my man
lord eric's gaming how you doing sir
oh man you know what i i i always love
coming your intros are just
but could i just like come back
it's always good to be back i love
coming to this podcast oh appreciate you
brother
appreciate you real quick so shout out
to the anonymous person who just bought
a
iop net gator salute to you sir get that
get that protect yourself from the
pandemic
i see you thank you we had to shout you
out on the show yeah make sure
you keep that on your head
[Music]
obviously it's successful
[Laughter]
finish we got cat daddy with the five
dollar super chat be sure to check
king david on the creative feature he
dropped some gems of course
he already know salute but let's get
back to laura first of all man brother
it's always
a pleasure to have you man it feels like
it's been forever
first of all how are you doing you know
saying what you got going on
i'm good man yeah just just uh you know
trying to trying to keep busy a prisoner
in my own home right now you know
it's really like locked down but i still
love to be fair unfortunately you know
it's uh
we might be in crazy times but i can
work from here i can
grow the grow the empire from here so
we're still we're still keeping it going
we're still uh
covering games working on things trying
to trying to get ready to be i'm working
on being the i'm working on being the
real kratos
let's go i see them video game bro
you'll be inspiring man i i love what
you're doing
with the fitness aspect it and one thing
you know at least i try to preach at
king and everybody we
you know as gamers you know we got to do
better about our health
right we got to do better about our
health we gotta we gotta monitor it man
a lot of our brothers in the gaming
community
are really afflicted with a lot of
things and let's be real as much as
gaming you know we could sit in the
house be stationary and okay
but we also gotta be able to be active
do things but i love what you
well kind of just real quick i just want
to know what it what really inspired you
to be like you know what i want to do
this
so i i think it's funny because like the
thing that sort of got me into
originally though back where because it
started in 2016
in the end there i was i used to be like
overweight and like um and then i would
always
it was really pokemon go that was kept
the catalyst like i was i would
no i got no time to go to the gym but
then i was spending two hours going to
catch like a stinky
probably not right here so something
clicked in my head but i but prior to
that i'd always gone to
like those sort of like local gyms where
you can get a membership for like five
pounds and i was like
and then you never have an incentive to
go because you're like oh it's only five
pounds right so then
when this happened i went to one of
those like expensive health clubs but
you pay stupid like
like too much right but i was like if
i'm paying that money i'm not going to
waste that money
right and then i paid and i was
fortunate because i paired up with like
a pt who like i'm still you know you saw
my friend to this day
um he kind of got me through it but he
um i said someone's like look right i
wouldn't lose this weight
i hate cardio he's like i'm a strength
coach i was like all right cool so then
we started so he started lifting and
suddenly
the process went from just me initially
starting just because i wanted to lose
weight to suddenly like oh yo i love
lifting like
you know i'd always been this guy i went
back at school where i'd try and skip
any kind of physical
you know if there was there was like pee
or gym class i'd be like ah let me go do
some studying
[Laughter]
whereas like now i'm just like yo like
you can't keep me out the gym just look
down
like now i'm just like i've got to buy
the equipment at home so um yeah it kind
of got to that and then obviously as i
as it went from being something i just
did to get healthy yeah it became like a
like
i'm just as passionate about fitness as
i am gaming now so i started to learn
about it i you know i follow like
and then i spend a lot of time because
the first few years was just me
not knowing like the good information
from the bull crap out there right
so you know i'd spend time starting a
new program and i'm already reading like
how to do a better program it's like no
no you need to be consistent so then i
started to learn stuff
and then i realized that a lot of that
stuff that is out there is just made
needlessly complicated so then i was
like
i want to try and make this easy to
understand for gamers so that people
people could be like you know these
because gamers like my people right i'm
just like i want to become the bruce lee
of it
yeah but strip away the bs and you want
to get right to the
yeah yeah because because that's the
thing so i don't i don't have
aspirations to go and train sort of like
athletes and stuff but i'm like if i can
help gamers like
and we can also prove that like you know
you can still play games yes
and just like you know i i still i still
sit on my desk for like 10 hours a day
but i'm also
able to do that so um yeah so video
games kind of came to that and then the
more i did it i realized there's so many
like parallels as well like when it
comes to tracking macros it's like
spending xp points when you level up
like
it comes to like grinding like it's like
an mmo like you're gonna have evolved
yeah yep i'm in my mobs i'm doing my
lifts and i'm like and i'm getting a
little bit
like i'm you know level two level three
so like there's just so many parallels
so um
yeah i really to do that i really want
to make sure that like if someone wants
to be active
they can come to video games and be like
there's no bull crap here like you want
to know about nutrition i'll tell it to
you
simple i won't try to sell you something
i'm not going to say you need some dumb
supplement
relax yeah that's that's the goal man
bro proud of you man i love what you're
doing the growth is it's been tremendous
and
i mean did you a million man like subs
bro it's so much we've
talked about since you've asked me a
million subs right
how did that feel did you ever envision
yourself being that level of a content
creator
i mean honestly no because it's like
it's one of those sort of things that
you know when we started the channel it
was like me in 260 it was like his idea
back in the day
yeah and we um yeah i mean like you know
i
i kind of like we only initially did it
because we're like well you know we're
playing games and we just
like you know kind of helping people
let's make some guys but it was never
really something that i sort of saw
going there yeah um but it's weird
because like millions like it's one of
those
big numbers and like you think you think
you sort of like have this this
this big sort of shift but there's
something when we hit it it's like well
nothing's really changed cause we're
still gonna get back
wait wait hold on the check you're
grinding the million dollar publishing
clearance house check did it come like
there wasn't
i was i was i was like hey yo youtube
and well i'm supposed to be giving like
a house and a magician
yo you know what maybe early on in
youtube
when youtube was in his infancy
that was a thing like you know because
yeah the stories of
content creators making over four
hundred thousand a month i'm like ah
that's crazy
you're average don't get something don't
be a silent alex just turn your mic up a
little bit they say your bikes are low a
little bit so i just want to make sure
he said his beard his beard alone
deserves one million subs
why don't you say who said that
[Laughter]
oh my god dildo gagging salute
yes salute salute
[Music]
um i'll make sure the wolves eat you
know i support thank you
you gotta eat them all your family man
just put your name up dude no need for
that
no we love you um we got the living
flame with the five dollars but yeah
much love from quarantine lords
set up my new lg c10 and random
benchmark
being the hellblade 2 trailer looks like
60 frames my life has
michael aka bedsides finest two dollars
super chat zack snyder's justice league
trailer was fired so yeah king it was
the trailer not the are you happy
excited i was like but something was
coming yeah
yeah after after after i got off the the
the the podcast with a few i went to
double check
and it was like march 18th and i was
like okay whatever godzilla king kong
that month
yeah yeah i care more
oh i'm watching more godzilla content
right now and
you know they only had that one moving
king kong looked really wild and they
really need to
fix it up but i've never anticipated
something like that
i'm sorry i'm i'm i'm there i'm super
excited for it yeah
i really asked what's up i was scared
that that wasn't gonna happen
yeah yeah i was totally afraid last
question for lord
eric's oh you still want to switch out
one more one more we have atl with the
five dollar super chat
you guys were great with game on daily
show yesterday thank you thank you
thank you i appreciate it further
insight into your history was phenomenal
that addict and king destiny stream was
funny
[Laughter]
absolutely so much love to support yeah
we were on gas game on daily check us
out
did a little origin story yesterday that
was kind of funny you didn't like me
though yeah yeah i know yeah
it's kind of crazy right now yeah really
a lot of smoke a lot of smoke
but uh real quick so just also like have
you got a chance what have you been
playing recently just wanted to know
that uh so i think mainly we're at the
moment it's been
it's been the most sunrise demo uh
initially because obviously that drops
next month that's gonna be a big one for
us
and you know what i got back into just
literally this weekend um
neo2 but playing it specifically all
in co-op friends
i didn't realize because like a lot of
those time when you play those souls
games like you know co-op's a little bit
janky because
someone dies and then they get kicked
out and then it's just a bit of a ball
leg to do that whereas like neo2 has
actually got like a cool expedition mode
so we've been running through the whole
game just like everything in cold but
it's been a lot of fun nice nice yeah
man you're known for that monster hunt
i i i love boston and now the neo with
the souls aspect
that's pretty good man i'm hearing good
things solve you you're messed with neil
harcourt last time right i
he kneeled one definitely i didn't get
neo too but neil won
if you remember that i we had it laugh
when i oh yeah
his name was william i like the sam so
this is how much of a purist i am i'm
like yes i'm automatically assuming it's
asian culture or whatever whatever
so i was like yo tell me about it he's
like yeah the guy's name's william i was
like
[Music]
uh we got the living flame with the two
dollars of attack whereas attic he's
missing the kingdom hearts
sadly he hadn't seen the bushes i don't
know where he's at i know why
yeah i'll get to that one we all cut up
soft
yeah we're good we're good all right and
you know we already got the four where
we don't have four horsemen of gaming
today
we have three horsemen one of them is
missing and then the bushes put an apb
out for attic let us know if you see him
or his whereabouts
he was last active three hours ago on
social media
and we think he is firmly in the bushes
so hopefully he will be able to make the
show
after blazing gaming last night most
likely shout out to is that antoine
antoine williams
just figured out who sadness was makes
sense now oh you're talking that medium
talk okay okay
salute okay already know but we still
got those other horsemen and of course
the most technical gaming lord
the solo gamer who lives with a single
player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity
and lord patreon of the iron bank my man
lord sovereign how are we doing sir
i'm in the bushes today man
recovering from yesterday
we're doing ot we're doing serious ot
man i had to apologize
to guys i'm like this is our influence
you know this right like these four-hour
marathons this is what we do
yeah we're gonna be a little shorter
today
yeah for sure so uh shout out to the
keys williams because he posted a
purchase that he made this morning and
made me laugh
because uh i'm not proud of myself
you did it i i folded i folded it i'm
starting
out to the screen for this game
[Music]
there you go for the expansion the 200
listen listen the sticker shock at the
beginning was
i just have an issue with paying so much
for something so small exactly
yeah but the moment i started
downloading with reckless abandon
went away i was gonna forget i'm
i got my usb 3.0 caddy on the side alex
i'm downloading anything i look at you i
look at the gate oh you're over 80 gigs
you go
over you're going over there and when
i'm ready to deal with you and i'm
actually
actively playing you then you get the
opportunity
to get on this nvme velocity
architecture sir
that's what we're doing you are on the
bench i brought four of them
because i knew exactly what was going on
they are in place
and i already have my uh my 19 terabyte
over there on the side
so that happens how it happens yeah man
i gotta go with king understand let's do
it listen do it let it go
yo
no you need some games for that hard
drive oh god bang bang
oh he got the smoke early no no but i
mean this is this is he's
he's actually true but y'all got all
those demos over there
y'all not using up y'all actually y'all
need a hard drive
are you implying that the players five
did not have a comparable solution
they said that we got an expansion bay
for nothing
y'all messy you know shout out to eric
for being better joining us on our
messages
so yeah that's it um actually yeah so
because i had all of this illustrious
space now
i downloaded pretty much everything that
i owned that uh was series x compatible
um optimized so i actually got into the
division two yesterday just to see it
see now mind you i see the thing is the
game play
the world or something how dare you did
vision two is a game that you could
really play by yourself if you wanted
that's 60 hits different yo
man man i was playing division two when
would i ever say that i planned division
two
see eric's i told didn't i tell you that
before the show about the division two
like is and i'm like damn it sucks
because they actually
have a viable product if the content
was more forthcoming if they're on a
consistent cadence
and yeah it doesn't have it can't be how
destiny's got
this it has to be double the time
right they have to double march because
destiny already has built that
that foundation those raids is epic
people have
real memories of those rates right i
have real memories
of divisions right yeah division isn't
it so at
least at this point it isn't that right
um but i will say like
even comparing it to gears when you talk
about the the getting into cover getting
out of cover moving obviously
they're not as heavy as gears characters
right but it feels smoother and you know
when you mantel over something and you
just keep running and it's like
i forgot how smooth the gameplay in that
game is
and that 60 is just another story i hope
they bring it to that new
the new uh uh mmo that they're working
on
all that knowledge that they did acquire
because the world look
rich you know like you look up at the
buildings and they
really go all the way up it's not
clipping out or something like that
i'm really excited to see what massive
could do with star wars
yeah with that because i don't think
it's going to be a jedi game right i
think it's going to be a shootie shootie
game man
they're very good at shooting shooting
like they're very good
yes snowdrop looks phenomenal one thing
about division that engine
really looks good i want to shout out
somewhere else
the medic man looks like i just missed
you but i want to shout you i saw it on
my phone
shout out i see you with that deck gator
sir salute you know what i'm saying get
there
feed the wolves feed the wolves make
sure you get super chats off and every
morning
all right then we got gerald mack with
the five dollar super chat good morning
good brothers peace and blessings to the
iop podcast
looks like it's going to be a good show
great guest let's
get it we already know we got the
legendary eric's gaming in the building
what else we have
we got we got family neil mentioned with
the 5 super chat with the dot dot dot
it only hurts for a second spend that
220 no i'm not i'm
i can't justify it when it's 200 and
something i can get a series s
at that point before that's true that's
true
you know what i'm saying it's like one
of those things my rooms are ready
so i okay so now i have the extra cash
do it now i thought about the thing
about that is though
for the series s right when i do
eventually get one right when there's
one available now able to grab it
just to put in the room or whatever
that's the memory card i'm gonna be
taking out of my console back and forth
and boom boom boom
and so you know listen man
it was super painful to press the the
add to cart button
and once i popped that into the console
it was over like i
i downloaded everything under this
reckless event you got your freedom back
you got your i did i don't want to shout
out
great i want to shout out before super
chat normally we yeah
man we gotta shout him out because um
yeah that's what he was in the house my
brother let's go
you know what i'm saying he always give
it up for what he does in the house of
salute and then um
last but not least i gotta shout out
dildo gaggins
uh he bought the netgator now so yeah
he's he's ready for the winter
dildo yeah he's out he's like oh wait
hold on i gotta read this
we got dealer gaming with the ten dollar
super chat
shout out to the one and only songs
thank you sir much appreciated my heart
was broken but
i i'm reborn today thank you yo
shout out to dealer because we be in the
party chat first of all he's a
he's a complete fool he's just the same
as he is on his show on the journey
so he's clowning me on my lap and then
he's clowning forte about eating teddy
grahams he's clowning him about
so he's like yo you don't even know it's
all for the podcast
i'm sorry you know dylan's a real woman
oh xbox live party trying to be poppin
salute the dealer what else we got
yeah we got and we got fonza riley the
goddamn gamer
five dollar super chat gamers have been
playing games outside of their comfort
zone lately
dealing with nba 2k and saab with a
multiplayer online game just proof
gaming is dry yeah
well it's not coming because gala was
playing um
that's saying destiny yeah yeah no but
you know what it is also it's that it's
that same thing like when you get a new
graphics card for your computer
let me see how the old stuff runs i've
always loved doing that so
it's kind of like the same thing all the
stuff that you don't want you know
that just runs and looks better on the
software you're implying that also
gamers play old games on their new
hardware is that something
yeah oh you know people say that they
don't do that they don't just yeah i
don't know but all of a sudden yo
i can't believe people call a year old
game an old game i'm like
dude what like are you bugging like i
don't know
you're gonna tell me that no one with
the new patch just dropped for um
god of war no one turned on a
playstation 5 and said let me see what
it looks like
60 frames with a real 4k not that
checkerboard crap that we have with the
pro
the real stuff let's let's get to it
especially especially since that game
isn't on pc
yet well i mean all that stuff would get
to that point but
it's if who doesn't want to see the game
that they love
facts better better yeah
yeah it was what gave gamers are
selective it's when it's their favorite
they don't have a problem yeah all of a
sudden it's all good to play all the
stuff
yeah back and fast people get hyped
about mass effect trillion but hey what
we got for the super chat
we got uh we got slow mo back slap with
the five
i followed eric since back when he did
mostly division content great youtuber
ask him if he still plays division or
not
alex uh no it's not at the moment i it's
one of those games that much like
destiny i follow it newswise just guys
so i know what's going on
um but honestly like yeah it kind of got
to the point where there wasn't a great
deal that was kind of keeping me playing
um i definitely wasn't going to sort of
just cover it for the for the sake of
doing it so i just sort of yeah
i took a little backseat uh if it and
then when the new stuff comes out if
it's cool i'll jump back in
yeah um but yeah like honestly to be
honest i feel i
i guess we'll get on we kind of talk
about um stuff but i just feel like
the looting genre it just kind of just
needs a bit of a break anyway like
there's a lot of
just uh driving we'll probably touch
touch more on that on the anthem song
but yeah for now divisions on uh
on the shelf no i feel you about that i
mean i want to shout out slow mo too
because i did
like the destiny division content we
used to come used to get informative new
and i loved
one of your past interviews you had
pushed the division devs
about if reigns were in the game and i
was like i love that you it was a
fantastic interview
you always kill it with that but yeah
salute to slo-mo definitely we we
of course it's all it's all good to take
a a break from that stuff you got bots
to hunt to the world you got all that
other stuff you played you're good
you're good
okay
yo that tetris effect connected really
oh my god it's so good it's so good
i gotta fight it yeah no doubt no doubt
i'm not like i say dudes think i'm
capping with their game pass and stuff
i don't care what you know and says the
level of freedom
that you do have one when you have the
extra space because both consoles
are a little bit constricted yeah you
know but one has an out
um and the fact that when you get into
the game pass arena
the part take yes you know some things
you look at you're like
let me try that you know you know
there's just a lot of people don't have
disposable income to go in the game stop
and look on the wall and go
let me try that i don't got let me try
that money to be
upset with a game on the wall that i
purchased when i got home
you know like oh because you looked at
the the cover art and he was like oh
this looks nice and you got home he was
like oh it's trash
oh yeah live through that no
no no absolutely solid we all caught up
sir yes sir we're good
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the access gamer oh late
the prophet of xbox king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
oh beloved lord king how are we doing
sir
i'm doing fantastic my boy eriks is here
i'm gonna tell you right now guys
if you don't know he is taller and
bigger than you
think yes because i i swore i was like i
thought he was short
he was like yo kick david i was like
what
oh my god i said and he's taller
than what i think i was like oh my god
the beard is
[Laughter]
everybody that saw me get my holy grail
hulk buster
you know that says six thousand dollars
in your face um
but uh you can move him into different
positions like you can take that uh
that chess piece out and put that iron
man inside as he's busting out
it's the light up features and stuff
like that that kos is coming i got tons
of videos uh for
that hulk this and that and all that
other stuff i was doing so many
unboxings i didn't get a chance to do
any kos i do apologize guys what i've
been playing is destiny
2 the new season drop and
season of the children we all know when
the new season dropped
getting your light level up to max cap
is
crazy so right now i'm probably like uh
probably 10 lights away to get to max
cap
we've been grinding really hard uh i was
playing with attic last night
and um in gambit and i i found a new
strat
and it's called the divinity strat uh i
know i didn't make it up but
uh i don't i can't explain how much joy
i get out of playing the uh destiny with
attic
yeah he's funny and destiny one
and nobody really knows the story i met
him as room to kill
inside a room and he became a real good
buddy of mine even before it was the
podcast stuff
and i came became super protected i
could become super protective of my
friends
facts right and it was one dude that was
just kept bothering this dude and
i i just got really fed up with it and
you know what i laughed about it
i was there for this and um but
we was playing yesterday and it was like
batman and robin or batman in the red
hood
or whatever you know equals lebron james
and dwyane wade
and we taking down the the the prime
evil
in seconds i'm talking about melting
them in seconds because i came up with a
certain strat
and he uh added to the strat on how to
do
and it was just like you know back at it
again buddy cop movie all over again
you know so he'll go inside here and
invade i'm like yo leave the heavy on
the wall and it was just
it just felt really really good and
something that we thought was gonna do
for
probably 10-15 minutes turned into two
three hours i heard y'all because we was
in the same party chat doing traveling i
was listening to y'all
and y'all was getting your strats on
with the melting down man yeah that's
what's
just so much fun but um i finished uh
the medium you guys know and
i was so pleased it it hit that uh
that silent hill spot for me okay i wish
it was a little bit longer i didn't like
the ending
um and i i hope they do go back and fix
some of the technical issues of the game
i know the game is
super demanding i watch digital
foundry's uh pc
um you know comparisons of the game and
i know it's super demanding and also if
they can refine the tech to it i think
it's something that's super viable
really nice i'm looking forward to a
couple other games and i'm also playing
um
dragon quest uh so in between
this i'm going this way and i've seen
you in like two years when you're dead
i know you know what i knew it and i
purchased the game
yeah so i'm like if it comes out of game
pass whatever i always have it
i got to put the fraud light on myself
because
uh you know you you highlighted it
yesterday
and you've been he's you surprised me
what's up you surprised me with yakuza
um you really did
um because you from like a dragon he's
been on that
from when he saw it in the showcase i
was lukewarm on it
uh and he was completely on it and he he
purchased it
he played it and then every yakuza
he was just on it so he actually fell in
love with that world
and phil dominance maximus aurelius
spencer
went to japan and fought for us
to get playstation games that are
normally only on a playstation 4x
that is culturally central in japanese
culture to live in a breathing
environment
and game pass and and get a level of
content that's there and that game
launched day and date
we don't think about that and a lot of
people acted like there was there was
nothing there i'm like you got it
bro that's why i threw up though who did
that for you i was like yo he did that
for me
and what interrupts you is that i know
some people's like oh rts i don't like
it
this is really not like that because
it's so cinematic
and it's so in it's interactive like
it's like press the button do the combo
like
it's they add fighting game elements to
it the story and the graphics are good
and it almost you know i like it so much
king is that
it's the spiritual successor to shenmue
in my
opinion that open world it's just so
good but continue i just wanted to shout
you out yeah no so
i said okay i'm going to start from zero
and i'm going to
work my way you know and do the story
and and because now i'm super intrigued
in in this world and the fact that
there's a lot of rumors
in them acquiring sega
i want every xbox and every game pass
owner and it's 18 million of you guys
right
since they want to use that baseline as
18 million right
[Laughter]
game pass users i'm talking to each and
every last one of you
i want each and every last one of you to
interact with yakuza
at some point in time to show the
metrics to show that sega is viable
and it has a breathing space in game
pass
you might be the catalyst for them to
purchase sega if they see the engagement
levels on sega games go
up in game pass you never know it might
be something as small as you just trying
it out
that might tip it in their favor to show
that they're a viable entity i don't
know but i'm gonna try
if even if even just to show other
publishers and other developers that
that that the xbox platform is viable
for japanese games and we're
you know we still we're not there's no
neo on the xbox
yeah um things like that where it's like
you know these these devs look at the
playstation platform like well this is
viable for us
and they look at the xbox and they look
at what they assume they would sell on
the xbox
and it doesn't work you know obviously
game pass opens up different avenues for
those games to make it to the xbox
platform but
um yeah you guys got to show the love if
you don't show the love
it ain't happening it's dry up really
quickly factual factual know that that's
all you've been playing
sir yeah you know and um like when i
finish right now
being that is a love day uh
you know my division love is dead
my destiny love is dead i'll be watching
movies and tv you don't sound like
you're thrilled
[Laughter]
i'll be slow down watching tv
shout out to valentine's day that's
[Laughter]
watching the lords on break let the
lords break bread no doubt man
no and we have cedric h with the 20
super chat
stopping by to show some love we'll come
back to listen later thank you brother
appreciate it no thank you cedric all
caught up yeah all right cool and of
course we have the gaming ninja himself
this [ __ ]
no beat lord cognitos bring that
realness in a roman iop
that'll tell you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear shout out to
the last word my bro ebantis
had a good show shout out to the
manodestra
fun show he's a musician in gaming
really good content created we did some
real cool destiny talk we ranked some
raids we had some fun
check that out the last word is up on
iowa podcast youtube channel right now
if you missed the live show we did that
and then yeah man that's the i've been
playing a lot of that obviously um
season of shows is really good y'all
it's really good i mean they came off
beyond light was a great expansion but
generally the
expansion the seasons that come with the
expansion tend to be weak so season of
the hunt
that was additional to the beyond
lightnings eh very light
but this man they're really doing a good
job narratively finding out what's going
on with the crow
and osiris and saladin and just finally
narratively bringing things together
against a common threat
and um i love the new activities trials
came back this week
good debut for trials of osiris good
debut especially on console
didn't encounter as much cheaters some
great new loot fantastic egyptian swag
messenger uh pulses out it's it's fire
340.
i got it god bless i would love to
he was in there so we could do that and
we gotta read i gotta go i gotta read
with you um probably after the podcast
if you are
oh no you're not you don't know
you're a lockdown
[Laughter]
please help me please
but yeah it's been destiny's been good
he folded my yakuza a little bit this
week and followed
my second run uh tactics and hitman but
um yeah man that's what i got
solved real quick i know we missed last
week uh just to do our patreon winners
and all that yes
yes sir so once again thank you to all
our patrons and youtube subscribers you
know we do every month you know
give back to the community so why are
you so smooth with it did you
i don't know it's kind of crazy
right now valentine's day edition of the
patreon i was like
oh he's really getting that demographic
up for us right now
i gotta do my part you know
all right let's get into this ten dollar
gift card giveaway
and the winner of the ten dollar gift
card
pick on fusion congratulations no
doubt hello friends see me in the dms
and we will take care of that
nice then we have the 20
gift card giveaway and that goes to
[Music]
sammy prescott minnie
oh wow sammy please oh crap no doubt
all right we have our teespring giveaway
let's go who wants to drip who want that
eye
lord drip and the winner of
our teespring giveaway
atrocity nights congratulations
yo you ain't wicked this time these are
unique names
so once again thank you guys catch me in
the dms i will look for you as well
sometimes like as i've said in the past
it's difficult because if you still
support us on youtube and you don't have
twitter or stuff like that it's very
difficult to find you so if you listen
to the podcast
you guys in the chat if you know the
person that's won
make sure to hit them up let them know
so they can uh reach out to me right
absolutely absolutely and um real quick
to uh yeah
so obviously we've got lord alex in the
building a lot of times before we jump
into the top i did want to ask him
because he
he's been usually have an annual thing
with you lord alex and um
the last time but your first appearance
was iop 68
i was like wow 68 that was a long time
ago but um what i won this though is
at that time we started we were doing
top five this was your top five video
game
franchise of all time you had zelda the
franchise
you had monster hunter you had smash
bros
pokemon and world of warcraft i need to
know has any of this
changed since then okay okay yeah
i reckon it has i reckon because you
have fact yes yes definitely
let's go is this is this franchise or
specifically game
either it could be a franchise all your
favorites
um
i i'll still group zelda because there's
so many zombie games that they just it
would just fill the top five
monster hunter uh number like
maybe number three i don't know three or
five uh so i've gone back and played god
of war finally
it's one of those weird games that came
out when it when it first came out there
was just like other stuff going on so i
never finished it so finally
um yeah i did that i'm ready for because
i because obviously i'm like
being into osmotology so so the ending
blew you away right
oh yeah it blew me away but also because
i've because i specifically there's a
lot of things that
i feel like i appreciated because uh
because i read about like north
mythology there's a lot of additional
week that i mentioned
i was like oh yo oh yeah this is mad
yes yes so the subtle parts are like you
know with like a trace and like the
the mistletoe i was like so yeah
that's uh this is yeah so when i with
ragnarok i'm like i cannot wait to see
where they go with this
so i'm sorry so which one did dad take
out or as you said whole new five i'm
just curious
so uh i'll drop water walker off for
that okay
okay so gotta walk and go in there
it happens you know and because world of
warcraft was huge but it never
it never made my top five all right but
it was always huge in my life it did a
lot of things
no doubt so it's other remains
definitely still always like have that
special places like that sort of like a
connection with mmos but yeah there's
definitely a especially considering
i'm hoping for i'm hoping like when lost
art comes out that's going to replace
that fully you know
what that's why going back to what you
say in earlier king as well about like
kind of showing support on like game
pass like when crossfire comes out
yes i don't even want to play that game
but you need to play that game just to
show them the support because yo the
kind of studio
will give us lost ark so like it's a c
even just if you download it and play it
once just so it gets the numbers
that's facts no i agree it's a huge it's
a huge thing people
you got to realize your level of
interaction
actually means something now because the
metrics
you're not in a vacuum anymore
everything that you're doing is tracked
and being seen
so and do think if they play the game
it's just uh for them no actually it's
an
algorithm that shows what's viable
and what's not viable and what they're
going to invest
money in or what studio so when
accusations happen
you don't think doom going to game pass
or doom on
on a platform of bethesda games on a
platform didn't play a huge
part in signing them and seeing like
okay well a lot of their games
rate high and our interactive you know
so you have to look at those things but
eric's
you're completely on to something 100
you're right yeah man
yeah man so again so zelda monster
hunter god of war has entered the fray
world of warcraft has left does smash
bros and pokemon
still remain you know i still think they
do you know because
because the thing is it's one of those
weird ones where like because i've kind
of
done like a mix here like god of war i'm
only putting there specifically for the
new god of war like
i'm not a fan of the older ones me too
um whereas zelda i'm putting there is
like a group franchise because like
honestly
that would be three that would be in the
first one uh same goes for monster
hunter
and the same kind of thing goes pokemon
some of the recent pokemon games haven't
like
hit with it as as much but they're also
still one of those series that i would
just love no matter what and it's also
one of the few series where i
i just don't like turn-based it's just
me though i'm just not on topic but
pokemon is the exception i'm like
i'll just deal with that
i think he accepts it as an obsession
that's it
[Laughter]
that's one of those ones where i'll just
i'll just contradict myself fully up
like yeah
these games are dusty these games are
boring they're slow i haven't got time
for them everyone's like what about
final fantasy that game is dusty
the thing that we did debut when you
were last here was
favorite console of all time and why
okay pc easy nintendo switch
the game that's the first time oh
switch you
this is again one of those ones where
like i'm okay i'm a massive nintendo fan
boy i'm hugely biased for this side
don't ignore speech speak your truth
like i've i grew up as a nintendo kid
when i was younger right i didn't even i
didn't even get a playstation until ps3
i didn't get an xbox to 360. i was a
nintendo kid
like whole i didn't even know anything
existed
[Laughter]
with me growing up like i've always
loved portable gaming and
portable gaming so like literally the
nintendo switch for me i know it's not
like the most graphically powerful i
know but like i've always been gameplay
first traffic second so for me
the switch is just everything i'm like i
can take it with me i get my handheld
fix
i come home i sit on the tv it's got all
the games like all my favorite
franchises are basically on this system
for the most part
it's done like i don't need i mean if
they make a 4k version i'm not going to
complain but like switch
is best console ever
whoa no no as a representative of the
switch gang
i do have to challenge you on one thing
because you are on fire right now i love
what you're saying
we need us to band together
and fight for online messaging and voice
chat because it's such it's so stupid
that it's not
there when the previous console had it
and it to me would be
perfect like it would be the perfect
thing to finish off the iso
to take on a great system i think it
would break the machine
break the machine maybe you might get it
with a
switch pro or whatever that's the only
thing
because if you are my friend listen i
can't send you a message
this is a glorified stalker list like
there's nothing we can't talk about you
see
the friends list and how you have to get
on the list you have to put in a
20-digit code
to become a buddy like so at some point
in time
they have to simplify things they're
i i'm i'm a prisoner of the same thing
of saying
oh that's nintendo yeah type of thing i
don't play it as much so it doesn't
bother me as much as you guys
it bothers the hell out of college yeah
because i want to use this
this is really awesome it does it does
because it's it's
it's an unnecessary omission and i just
feel like
this is nintendo being nintendo in a way
and it's just like
i don't know the logic behind it i don't
know the thought process behind it i'm
just protecting the kids cod
oh brother they're protecting the
children they don't need
children messaging other children they
don't want that level of conversation
play your game and be gone
the first switch favorite console that
we've had on iop
so salute to you all songs from the chat
let's get the show rolling man we got a
lot of stuff though
yeah we got gaming for today with the
two dollars five dollars super chat
bro wonder if slo-mo is still listening
after all the destiny 2 talk
if this was dps he would have rage quit
the show
plus teddy grahams are amazingly good
yeah they are
salute to my bro gave before we gave we
got to get that trouser osiris done
yesterday man
he'll be getting my message of salute
finally all right then we got snowball
back slap with the pops
we need lost ark in the west that game
looks amazing could definitely fill the
void where diablo once was yes
a little dps podcast in the building
that is both
gaming forte and slow-mo backstab uh
brothers please support their channel on
each individual channel they do a thing
good dudes anyway let's get the show
crap one more
one more dragons tv with the five
dollars
no doubt good afternoon lords and shout
out to attic for grinding with me and
destiny to help me get my first good
weapons
oh maybe that's why you missed the show
oh
okay now the truth is coming out and
cogs stream deck xl pick up tomorrow
oh okay yeah put me on brother put me on
because is there a new stream deck yeah
i got we got to step by joints up yeah
for sure put me on bro you already know
with like a million buttons on it yeah
laura's got a million buttons i'm good i
need more emojis
continue what else we got and i think
we're good we're caught up yeah
all right cool um last week's poll
results are in
the people spoken to the question with
rumors of another potential microsoft
studio acquisition slash partnership
which
company would you prefer microsoft to
acquire the winner of the four-way
ilp vote up or lords of gaming.net y'all
so please check it out
you know what i'm saying um it is sega
japanese presence and classic ip group
coming in at second place at 60 percent
of the vote was bungie
makes sense after destiny and maybe
their new matter ip
third place at 13 of the vote was konami
metal gear solid
uh silent hill castlevania and last
place and eight percent of the vote was
i don't care
y'all still gotta stop stadia from
snatching up all your ips
evil state is out there so salute lord
solve your thoughts on this sir
i mean yeah man like this not just
because i'm a sega fanboy
and i know all of us here are um but
i tell you like when you look at those
old vip there's so much you could do
with that stuff not even
about bringing them back in in the form
that they were right imagine like an
actual 2b
size going sequel to shinobi or
something like that or another golden
axe game with like better production
values
but even taking those ideas in those
worlds and
taking the risk and the chance to blow
them out and maybe make a big
aaa game out of one of these franchises
like all of those things could happen
because those things have been dormant
for so long for each um
i would love to see that happen and i
would love to be
that if that happens i would love it
that that to be the reason why
they want to do that with those
franchises factual let me get oh
my bro 108. he's robbie said finally
super chat
cog is the switch police el capitan and
we need to make up versus hurt we need
chat on the switch and just picked up
super mario world and bowser fury see
that's the thing
which girls don't want to know what i'm
talking about because it's like gamers
are selective with what they want to
champion and we got to put pressure on
nintendo we need this
this is this is work they don't
didn't work
you know they have a social media
presence at all i think it's a farce i
think
fans make up their social media pages
nintendo's not even listening to you
yeah you better hop on
on a plane and go and scream at the top
of your lungs in front of their
buildings
like crash was back in the day and i
think that's the only thing that they
respond to
when they call the calendar outside what
is he talking about messenger
what is this messenger thing what's this
voice messaging thing
this voice chat that you used to have on
wii u yes that
anyway moving along lord solve you are
up let's get the show
popping yo e3
what is happening man e3 is back baby
pack your bags it's
backing no pack your virtual bags
all right so uh shout out to video games
chronicle um
they uh posted and printed an article
this week uh talking about
uh an alleged a leaked document that
only uh
sort of publishers were supposed to see
but they they managed to get their hands
on which indicated
uh the esa's plans for an all digital e3
event
in 2021 so if you guys remember last
year
they failed to pivot to a digital event
before it was too late and ultimately
they could not
change so they decided to not have an
event
at which point all the big third party
publishers
all the big all the big first parties
and and jeff keeley of course
decided to create sort of their own sort
of e3 events throughout the course of
the summer
um which probably spanned from june and
into into the early fall right probably
september that we started we saw
different uh events
so the esa sort of idea for
an e3 2021 is to have
what is essentially a week's worth of
coverage
um in a consolidated way the same way an
actually free would be
um and they're looking to partner with
the same people they partnered before
and they're looking for people to pay to
to engage in this virtual space that
only exists in the ether
right because their feeling is that
the the industry would benefit most
from a consolidated event as it always
has been
where it's sort of the uh the super bowl
of game
right where everybody's eyes are focused
on gaming for that one week
so basically that that is sort of the
overall pitch they're talking about
um having like two hour panels at a time
where you know the
their partners would be talking about
their games and what they're bringing to
the table
the rest of the year they plan on having
an awards event as well oh wow there's a
number of different things that they
have sort of planned
um and on paper
them trying to get back into it i i i
appreciate and i like right
um but at the end of the day what really
soured me on anything that i read
was the fact that they want to charge
people yeah
for this for for using these time frames
when the vast majority of these these
game publishers and devs
found ways to get their messaging out
there last year
individually on their own time in their
own way
um controlling their own message and
probably for considerably less money
right so my question to you guys what do
you guys think about this i know
i know we briefly yesterday on games on
daily uh
we talked about where e3 might be going
you know king had some thoughts but
what do you guys think in general does
does this even move the needle for you
guys
do you think it's stupid what do you
think before we get other lord alex to
jump on his
um just again for clarity everything he
said solved was was correct um so again
the plans have yet
to be approved by esa's members correct
this is something that's been
put out to esa members and it leaked out
to the to the press
right we're privy to this information
leak yes always leaks over there
very very very leaky very leaky over
there which is another
subject so so that's another thing right
because the
the big members of the esa are also the
same
companies that had their own events last
year correct so it is
it's very weird because at one end they
have the power to strike this down and
basically kill e3 and
now the question is is it worth it to
them to do that
just yet or because my personal feeling
really very quickly before i move on to
you guys
is that e3 only has
relevance if you can continue to make
an in-person show that's where they have
relevance that's what they've been doing
they have not found a way to digitally
be relevant and make the amount of money
they need to make
right and that's the big thing um and
then
offering you know offering people spaces
in your time slot you know when you're
the time slots you set aside for
you know six figures right is ridiculous
it's ridiculous when they
when a lot of these companies are doing
the same thing on a dime compared to
that
so i don't know and the last point
before i get before you average just
want to say that you see the plans
jeff kingly will now be involved again
he will be focusing on summer
game fest um no details on how many
people have signed up for this plan that
they
proposed me and apparently it is a six
figure sum
to join the program so lord arrex you're
up man a lot
i caught a little bit of your thoughts
on uh dcp side quest but i'm very
curious as
well any of your thoughts change evolve
how are you feeling about this uh
potential digital e3 for 2021
i mean i feel like the the concept of a
digital e3 in a more condensed window is
something that i like the idea of but i
think
the esa seem to think that they are
pivotal in e3 when they when they
realize that the only reason they were
there before is because they were the
physical event holder but they realized
that you know you think back to like
previous years as well when like esa had
been a dog house for a while you know
like people were moving out from there
expensive they leaked all the details
they're not exactly like anyone's
favorite topic right so like
it used to be a it used to be a sensible
thing to do because like all right
everyone's going there this time of year
so obviously i'm going to go to e3 i get
that right but
now it's digital everyone as you say
everyone can control their own space
in their own messenger you you think
that's like one of the challenges of e3
from a publisher point of view is like
oh i'm having to like juggle my
conference around sony or xbox or like i
want to go a different time am i going
to have to go
you know so suddenly they're like oh
we're going to be forced into an esa
window and you know what happened
they'll be like oh the
the big the big dogs will get their
their prime time window i'm going to be
like shoved in some like 11 p.m or 1am
window like they're like why why do i
want to do that like it makes it makes
sense and like nobody you know nobody is
going to kind of go to them now
especially considering they didn't pivot
last year if they if they were like
super reactive they were like all right
bam
we've got you guys like a week of
digital three we're like oh they they've
already sorted this
maybe you would be more inclined but now
we know that as of last year you know
obviously jeff keaney's done what he's
done he stepped in to kind of fill some
sort of void
um past all the companies like we can
just do ourselves like you know we've
been streaming for all this time and you
look at what they've done the past year
in like lockdown not even just
e3 people companies have adapted now to
to do remote capture events you know
they've got the software now so you can
just like
dial into their their machines you know
so you don't even need to go to events
anymore
so honestly i think yeah i think i think
i really like the idea of them
condensing things because the one thing
that i didn't like
about and i think he's addressed that
he's gonna change that summer games fest
as a concept was cool but the fact that
he dragged out for three months
agree not great i agree i had an issue
with that yeah
it's like the nice thing about yeah you
guys you guys probably feel the same
like you know you have your e3 rush
you cover all your content you chill for
a little bit in like july
then you start getting ready again this
was just like suddenly it was three
months of e3 and then games are coming
out i'm just like i haven't had a break
like what the hell man
but jeff did say on twitter he said that
he's looking to condense uh summer games
into like
a month now which is still a big chunk
but considerably smaller than before
yeah um but yeah i i mean i definitely
think so i think i think 100 it would be
cool
it's a weird thing because obviously for
gamers i would definitely like it if
they could
make a week event out of it because it's
it's a little interview we're like oh
yeah it's just
it's hype for a week i get from a
partial point of view you're like why do
i want to compete against like a
particular call of duty or a battlefield
when i'm a
smaller game right i might as well wait
two weeks and then get my my time in
this
so i get they have more of a media cycle
yeah that's what you're saying exactly
so i feel like from uh from an
individual standpoint
it doesn't necessarily make too much
sense for us i would like it but yeah
not the esa esa can
then i feel like their days are done to
be honest this is big this is a big
super chat kick
uh we got dan the man cunningham i love
that name
greetings lords i love the social aspect
of e3 but coverage has killed it
i actually like having the new spread
spread out keep games in the news that
that's true i mean that is true it just
i don't know it's just the way it
happened last year it's like okay
another one
another one in other words i like the
consolidation
but again maybe maybe in a physical
event that works better
right um black ronin with the five
dollar super chat shout out to erickson
iop
linking up like freddie gibbs and
grizzly bars
that's another concern right that that
beyond
the the six figures numbers that they're
asking of these publishers to join their
stream
they're also going to charge people to
access their streams in the same way you
would access
you know the the like the gamer like
like that
so oh that would be a critical mistake
that's a speculation i don't know if
that's
but again that might have been something
that was in the document that actually
leaked out as well
and um i don't know but that's that's
something that they're speculating about
and that would be that would be why
yeah that would be wow unless see there
was also a mention about
the potential for like digital demos
going out
to consumers and stuff like that and if
they can
sort of if they can sort of lock that
stuff down where it's exclusive to the
you know to the e3 platform right and
maybe okay i can see that kind of maybe
you know give me five bucks and i have
access to the demo that
no other uh platform has no i don't know
i am very curious about kickstarts on
this i know e3
is very special to him yet i know
obviously because of
the situation the world is in right now
and what's been going on we missed out
on
last year big plan for last year's e3 by
the lords which
really sucked because we were trying to
bring the community together king did
tremendous planning so i
am very curious my bro what are you
feeling about this we have not talked
about this it's digital
e3 2021 version what's your feeling
this is the definition of tone def
um is the
literal definition of my throne is too
high i can't see your peons
this is the literal definition of
i gotta hold on to the bag at any cost
chasing the dollar destroyed you it
destroyed you
the moment you opened the doors to the
public you were already in a sinkhole
that you couldn't get out of
and that was when it definitely went
down because i was available
to see it before and after
i saw your pitfalls before you saw your
pitfalls
i saw the the money hungry
uh entity entered the building
after you took it away from the only
people that could side with you
the only people that you had in your
corner which was the journalists
and the developers those people those
people that you had there
that was for you that needed your event
you turned it to monetize it for
for cash game that's the only reason why
you said we got these days i got to get
these people in
and we can make boatloads of money was
the boat loads of money worth it because
they did it they did it without thinking
about how do we do this to appease
everyone remember everyone remember the
year it was the fans and they
should have just did it to appease the
media
and your developers and your convention
would
it would still it would still be going
on now
you wouldn't have gave the doors to jeff
keegley to open to come
in and steal your corvette your corvette
is gone
it's down the block and he's not
charging anyone and he's doing such a
phenomenal job
he took your girl and made her better
you know you break up with your
girlfriend you think she's going to do
worse but y'all her next boyfriend is
she looks i've never met her
she looks fantastic kudos to
who kudos to he's a better guy than me
so this is exactly where you are at
right now and you're scrambling
trying to figure out how you can win her
over we're gone
pax sorry and pax was at a unique time
and let me explain why pax was in the
beginning of the pandemic and
while the before the pandemic reached
this apex or reached
it's not even concerned because
obviously it's still going i guess
but pax had the opportunity to still
give you packs still keep their soul
right right because pac's soul is indies
india
and indies is the is the complete
forefront yeah you have some mages there
but for the most part they don't care
sony didn't show up
they did not care they had their indies
and the indies is the show
you don't lose your identity right they
didn't lose that identity
and i think they're already poised for
taking that june spot because they knew
that the e3 event
will definitely be in disarray yeah they
have a plan you have to have a plan
this looks haphazard it looks like it's
a cash grab
oh we gonna charge you who the hell is
charging me to watch
your program i'm waiting for jeff
and jeff has been doing a great job so
i i think right now this is the
definition of tone deaf i think is uh
i can't lose my bag how can i get my bag
back
you messed up when you
took out your heart and soul which was
your journalists and your developers
and they need the platform they need the
time to talk to developers
get the skinny on the games that
everybody want to know about
that's gone now i gotta read this super
chat even if it's out of pocket
shout out to the shoe kingdom with two
last super shot jeff keegley is captain
save the game academic conviction
he executed his plan i don't even though
i feel too much power in one person's
hands is dangerous
i'm not gonna lie in this digital era
right he had the vision to see what we
needed going
forward right and he has executed in a
manner
that is gonna be hard to beat because
right now he's a juggernaut and people's
worrying about
what he's doing for the summer right and
now what e3 is doing
if i can save two thousand dollars on a
flight in a room
and you're gonna give me digital content
in the comfort of my home
right yeah i'm gonna miss bro time and
hanging out with the guys and going to
developers
but at the same time more developers are
being accessible to us
now opposed to waiting for one big event
and the price differential right because
all just yeah who's paying a million
dollars
i mean let's be real everything you said
is true because it's like we already
like eric said
we already seen the signs of the bigger
guys the eas
moving out the sony's moving out
everyone having their own thing during
three weeks so the writing was kind of
on the wall there let me jump in this
this is a good one because
i'm i'm so torn i'm mixed with it man
because it's like
you know how much e3 means to me you
know and how much it means to us i mean
eric's
you know we've got the classic story you
know i'm my first media uh
microsoft event i think it was 2018 and
um
i'm like man i'm in here like you know
the lord's the game
here like it was a it was a moment for
me you know i was very proud of what we
did and then i'm
shoulder to shoulder with my industry
heroes my icons on one side of me
it's the john lennon from digital
foundry i turned around i'm like yo
there's eric's in
two secs like yo i i had to be
professional to do my job but i wanted
the family i'm like yo let me take a
picture with you
you know what i said two things on the
camera saluted too soon to see your
growth is tremendous so
it was almost and then even before that
we would see you and pass it you'd be
going
from the west wing to the south wing and
you got your care you guys are
everyone's working but it was like a
fraternal thing it was a
it was so cool and and i i feel
for people who never experienced that
like think about there's people right
now as gamers that have
never experienced any they don't know
what it is to be at a press conference
they don't know what any of that is and
to me that's the essence
of gaming so this hurts obviously the
panda i'm not gonna blame everything on
essay the pandemic definitely has to a
factor here
yeah you know what i'm saying my
question was will it ever return so
we're seeing now the leaks are out
they're obviously thinking about it but
i'm working
you know paying and this this might this
doesn't sound like the wave and then on
top of that
like alex mentioned you just came off
a major breach you just came off like
you violated the integrity of
journalists
of so many peoples whose personal
information is
out there in the ether and you really
truly never
meet a culprit you never truly took
ownership of it
and say hey this is what we're going to
do so they got that going and then to
king's point
jeff is moving out here with jeff jeff
got your joint
what i'm saying and he got sony with him
and somebody's like nah we not
you know what i'm saying so you you've
got all these battles that you got to go
now the only thing and i shout out i
think it was no
other zinc said it because he's going
that king hard body in the chair he's oh
my god i know
if he's not in color sorry honestly i i
will give you lighting day because
you're a loyal iop fan
i hate you zinc but i don't see you the
only point other zinc does have that i
have to give him credit is that
this is what i'm curious now microsoft
and phil they have
always stood by the esa traditionally
even
last time when so then when sony pulled
out and microsoft was like no no
and they held back all those games and
didn't show you nothing but
they they still stood by them and they
still did the event the question is
eric's do you think that changes or is
the microsoft
relationship you know still going to be
you know in pocket i'm curious what you
think about that
i feel like again i feel like it's all
it would make a lot more sense if it was
physical so
you know i don't know here's because
this is the thing is it's like when you
have an event like this
if it was like if we were back to normal
now and lockdown was over you'd be like
all right maybe they're gonna try and
recover this year but
you know if we're talking about another
digital year you think yourself
two years of like no e3 like is it going
to be possible to go back to
like exactly how it was before sure
people like that so in that respect i
feel like microsoft can
you know obviously they've got they're
buying studios they've always got the
money they can like walk and run our own
event and we'll also hop inside
you know esa's event you know we'll just
show up in two places
it's more exposure i feel like they're
there they can afford to do that but now
it is like
an online space i don't think there's
any there's not really any value for
them because again you know they
they have so many their online teams
again they split it between their uk
team and the usd they have so many
different ways of hosting content now
i just feel like if we are especially
this year if this year is again looking
like a year of digital
i can see a lot of those big companies
should be like we're just going to run
our own event when it starts
um and also you have like especially
between xbox and sony i feel like
there's always that kind of
that constant sort of like oh we want to
we want to drop our events beforehand to
put some pressure on you
you know yeah if they were if they were
resorting to
esa they'd be like well uh you've given
us a block on like tuesday at 10 a.m
well that doesn't work so yeah i don't i
don't see i don't see this year then
them kind of unless they've got some
contact in place i don't see them doing
anything
yeah it's a it's an interesting question
man because again we got to see
and the only thing there's only one
thing i disagree with king is when we in
reference to
captain steele your convention um is
that
in theory i like what the idea of summer
game fest is
but to me i just this big person without
like the cadence is strange
you gotta tweak it because yeah just
like the game awards it's gonna take
tweaking like it's gonna take everything
i do say this
being that microsoft uh did pull their
stuff and they have their own building
i must say if any one of
the companies the big developers the
ubisofts the microsoft the eas
and ea access and stuff like that now
there's two caveats
right oh when you go get your
vaccination you do get a card showing
that you've been vaccinated
to you know so you do have this right
and some talks in the backgrounds of it
let me see how i worked this
yeah they'd be careful
there could be there could be an avenue
that we can get a fan fest right
yeah and uh the microsoft convention
hall is large enough to
hold uh 20 capacity right
and that will equal to uh fan fest
uh entries right and still have that
in-person uh stuff with
the vaccination cards that you would
need to have
and also having your mask on and
also being available to the public that
would
show a level of
fan service that would be second to none
now i can see microsoft capitalizing on
that i don't see
sony capitalizing on that for one reason
right pax they were the first ones to
pull out of packs
right and i believe it was because of
the region
and they wanted to get a control and
ahead of it i don't think
they're at the point where they will
have you at the sony hall
and stuff like that so i think microsoft
will be a little bit more
bold when it comes to that and i think
they understand because of the events
that i've been through
right and certain things that i'm
hearing i think they will be more
inclined to
if vaccinations are in place if uh
we're having clean sterile
environments and masks and everything is
being uh according to plan
they can do this event and i think they
might
dare to do it right and that would be a
bold statement
in my opinion right but as far as
e3 the convention itself i
honestly believe like you said people
were pulling out
i don't think it ever makes that whole
uh entrance again
they have to capitulate to a point where
they
they have to stop looking at the
finances
stop stop that first you know when when
when you put money before your passion
you'll lose
and this is this is this points to
something that we don't normally talk
about when we talk about e3 and the esa
right the esa's primary
form of of of profit is
e3 yes it's it's something it's like
it's
like 75 to 80 of how they make their
money is e3 right
so it's it's contradictory to a lot of
the other stuff they do because when
again when when your focus in terms of
making money
is something that is a trade show
and has become a fan show and the the
point of it is to
get people through the doors to make
money any which way you can whether it's
merchandising whether it's paying to
play a game whatever the case may be
that is what they do and and that is how
they
function so they have to it's hard
it's very difficult to to put that
message out there and not sound like
you're greedy because
that's what you need to do right but at
the end of the day also
we don't really talk about the other
functions of the esa
that perhaps they haven't been because
of this focus on money
and and e3 like i think these are the
real reasons why they were created right
when you think about
you know um the esa
organizing gaming in terms of like
creating a vision of gaming moving
forward right
gaming in general right that's that's
kind of the esa's job when it comes to
um like bringing in companies and kind
of showing them the way like this is
this is how you're productive in gaming
this is how you forward
um this is how you protect your ip this
is how you do
how you create partnerships like the esa
is in place to do
all of those things and it feels like
all of those things which would
to me like if e3 is failing on its own
but you're still doing a good job at all
this other stuff
then i think the esa belongs to right
obviously they have they
they have a place it feels like because
of this focus on e3 and their need for
e3 to be a thing and to be successful
and for them to make money
all of this other stuff that's to me
more important to the
to to to gaming moving forward is
falling to the wayside
right and at that point then you really
do have to ask about forget about the e3
stuff
what is this esa doing to further gain
further gaming which is the point of it
anyway
and and and to the king's point it just
feels like
it it feels like they're doing anything
to get money and you can it's obvious
when you see this stuff right and again
it's not this stuff
leaked obviously they some publisher
somebody somebody put the business out
yeah but the business
is look at them again look what they're
doing and then you know
they either stay quiet or they answer to
it or they pivot based on the reactions
they see from people online
but at the end of the day it's like you
have to be it's kind of like what
happened with microsoft a couple weeks
ago it's like
make the change but do it you have to
stop and think about how you're going to
be perceived when you make the change
and try to do it
in a way that creates the least amount
of friction as possible right
and they're not they just feel like
they're like give me give you me
like when you're talking about charging
people six figures
for a virtual online space
in your event it's like again again
this is something that came out of that
they didn't say that they didn't say it
but this they may pivot before it ever
becomes a reality
but you know it's fair to assume that
that was on this documentary
that them charging you was on the table
for millions and millions of dollars
it's like man and that when i go i pivot
back to the point that for them to be
successful in that way
it feels like they need to have some
sort of in-person event
um and then it goes back to the same
argument that we've had forever
they have not been successful at
pivoting that event
to satiate the boss
and satiate gamers and to me i mean
again i
i don't want to be like a backseat sort
of like driver here but it's like it
seems like
you have to extend it a couple of days
right extend it a couple of days it's
going to be expensive but then you give
the press their time
to do with their jobs and then you let
you let the fans come in
and make a you know a crap ton of money
on the fans
and i think i think that has to be a
balance yeah you get closer to what
to something a happy medium that makes
everybody somewhat happy
and i think that's the only way they
continue they survive and exist
moving forward i just don't know if they
have the foresight to do to do it right
that's the question
like i'll jump in real quick i'll make
it quick because we went on with this
but um yeah i hear all your points you
know um
i i it's obviously sad because of the
situation because of the pandemic
you know the question is going to be
like how do they pivot you know how do
they
you know we knew this virtual thing was
gonna happen we didn't know the extent
of how this thing was gonna play out as
far as you know
charging and all this other stuff you
know the only thing they need to be
concerned about in my opinion
is one like you said solve the
perception
two um we gotta see once
the pandemic comes down and we assume in
2022 hopefully
fingers crossed things will be from a
physical convention standpoint
right things would hopefully be back to
some level of normalcy right
in that event will there any be any new
challenges to the fray
right well like king was saying pax step
up we you know shout out to toby and
you know uh the german connect gamescom
games called moving out
on the game you know what i'm saying and
eric's always going to ask you quick
before we move on like
do you see any competitors in that space
not saying that e3 is never going to
exist i
i can see it so there you go still comes
back you know so i can definitely see
that but my question is like
do you think now you know these other
shows like i said again from my
understanding because i've never been to
one
i'm assuming you have alex you know yeah
tell us about gamecon like how serious
is that you know as far as competition
two and two and e3
so gamescom is still still is still huge
it's the biggest consumer show so it's
bigger than e3 in that respect because
it has a
huge like a much larger floor space uh
they have of course in recent years
still done announcements through game
gamescom
it's always typically been the e3 is
more of the like media driven whereas
gamescom is more than like
consumer show you do have a you do have
a press day for gamescom uh the
difference is that you go on the press
day
and the next day you can't move like
literally there's like hundreds of
thousands of people in there it is
terrific it's just like you want to get
a roofer
i'm not even kidding when i tell you
they're they're because they've got huge
spaces and
it's you can like you can walk from one
hole to the other in like 10 minutes on
public day
that's going to take you half an hour to
get out of the hallway because you're
like dude
you're just like yeah that was that was
kind of uh i mean i feel like gamescom
is still always gonna be a popular one
because it's driven by
the public it's more of a fan like a
giant fan fest i still feel i mean i
completely agree with you as well i feel
like e3
like e3 as a as a entity as a title
will always exist in that space even if
like it's never even if it's not like
the same event
i feel like if if we fast forward say
like five years and there's like a
replacement event people will still
always call it e3
because it's like yeah yeah you know the
power the power play will be we're kind
of talking about how someone holding all
the money
the joke powerful will be if like next
year jeff keeley books the staples
center
in the same weekend and he's like yo you
guys want to start my game fest and then
usa is like
what the hell yeah yeah but i think
i mean you know i know i know not he
might not be everyone everyone's like
not everyone's like a big fan of him but
they say the same time you look at like
where
you think about the first ever game
awards that everyone liked mocked
because it was a bit it was
kind of like right and look at it now
yeah i mean although although i think
the one criticism now is less game
awards and more just game trailers with
a couple of rewards but
i mean as you like you know you like the
you like the trailers anyway but
yeah yeah
we lost them
yeah i just i could see i definitely
just see like someone else stepping up
just sort of like you know there is
slightly more focus that people like
working with
um yeah so i could 100 see different
events i think if anything
like one of the things that would be
really good as well especially in that
sort of interim stage is that
where an event not necessarily esa's
driven but an event like that is useful
because a lot of the big companies have
their own platforms and their own voices
to just like
push their own announcements and make
them huge yeah i feel like some of the
smaller companies like the indies can
benefit from an event like that just to
give them a platform to like be shown to
more people
um so i feel like if in the interim what
would be nice is just have like an event
that sort of offers smaller studios that
might have struggled
either like they might struggle sort of
getting their message out just giving
them like a central platform to be like
for a week you can find out you can find
about a ton of like great indie titles
but then maybe it might be packs yeah
yeah it's gonna be interesting to see to
see what happens like i said a lot of
questions
glad soft brought this through up idiots
we chat before we move on sir
uh did we get any more chats we have uh
gaming times patrick with the five
dollar super chat
e3 is going the way of the dodo bird i
don't think the value proposition is
there anymore for the com
for the companies this situation has
shown them too much
yeah and that's again that's one of
those things it's like
why would i give you money to to be a
part of your event when i can control
the messaging
from my event um and i can as a as a
small
developer a small publisher can find the
space for my game
to to to not be obstructed by a call of
duty or a bigger
game so you know it's it's just there's
too many pluses to doing it yourself
fair enough sir yeah i think so all
right
lord king you are up uh you brought some
news to the realm that i wasn't aware of
and
in reference to the duel sets the dual
sense controller
yes what's what's going on man you want
to tear it up
yes so apparently um the uh basically as
far as the
uh the the dual sets obviously we know
about the the switch joycons
apparently having issues with drifting
and um
you know controller drifts so apparently
yeah there's been some reports so you
know i think even
um could talk with some entities players
have gone to social media to share their
stories about
dual sense drift um they show one when
you show the the the
the system kind of resetting itself over
and over with uh bluetooth turning on
and off um there was a
video of a player playing destiny and
you know you have the gun on the screen
and it was like constantly moving
you know to the left so some reports are
coming up
of of people experiencing why is he
smiling
because there's litigation now
i would never bring it to the realm
until there was actual
legal action so um yeah you know shout
out to kotaku who put this article out
because
they tried they actually experienced it
they tried hitting up to hitting up
support
and referred to them and um they were
told that dual sense drift is
is correct under warranty however you
have to pay for your shipping and
control it to a sony repair center
and the cost varies on a number of
factors so
yeah it's a you know possibly a control
of dead zone issues so lord king
you know there's your topic we'll
continue on this
well you know being that i don't play my
playstation really at all
um you know outside of the five hours uh
miles morales demo oh my god
i do say this right i do say this is
this is kind of disheartening
in the in the sense that the best thing
about the console
you know the controller is the probably
the one that has the most
issues right that class action suit i
mean it got so severe that they have to
band together
to you know tell sony that this is an
actual issue does this change
the way that they manufacture do it or
sense or do they remove
features that uh that can make the
controller
still keep the form factor but remove
some of the tech out of the
uh the controller that's causing these
issues because
if sony is saying okay you have to pay
for shipping which is out of
out of this is out of the realm of this
that's absolutely madness right i'm
selling you a product that can actually
break
but i want you to send it back to me but
you pay the ship and i'll fix it for you
but you pay the shipping you already
paid 500 bucks
a plus for it and for some dudes that
was scalping let's say one of the dudes
that brought it for me for three grand
and he has to ship it out to sony you
know i i think that's that's a little
bit
much i mean postage shouldn't cost
anything to these guys they should send
uh
like microsoft did for us when uh we had
the red ring in depth they send the box
you put it in the box you send it back
there was no questions asked and they
fixed it and and they got to the
where the problem was and they fixed the
problem on the consoles
i think sony needs to be proactive in
this they need to send the boxes out
send the controllers back send them as
fast as possible
to the help the of the customer feel
more
welcome to their platform opposed to
making the customer feel like that's
like attacking the victim
you understand right you're a victim
you're already traumatized by
you can't play you probably got to go
buy another controller till you get a
chance to play
if it's your primary console your only
console now you have to wait for this
controller to come back maybe you don't
have the 15
20 bucks to get the controller you know
to them and get it back on whatever
timely basis
right i just feel that the
it's something that can be fixed they
have to address it
and i think they should address it in
the fact that that shipping should be
free
that's my main problem okay you know
don't don't attack the victim the victim
should never have to come out of pocket
at all for anything they already did
they already
brought into your your product they
already brought into your system when i
go to best buy and i get the warranty
that's why is the greatest oh yeah i
will always champion them anything goes
wrong
my pc broke it was just the power source
eric's
i went in there and i was like you know
the power source is dead uh can i get
another power so she'll fix this
he said no we don't fix computers here
at geek tech he he he went inside the
his computer came out with a
gift card five thousand dollars and so
wow go get another
computer wow yeah that's it
no questions that i they took my old one
it was like bye it's
junk and i was like this is news
but and i went and got another pc so
when you have that level of customer
service where
the buyer doesn't have remorse and it
doesn't feel like the victim is being
shamed or
you know you're afraid to raise your
hand when you have an issue
i think that's the best and i think they
really need this opportunity they can
step up and they can be a hero now
to those people that are in distress and
i just wanted to see that
nothing lord eric's man i was just
curious uh
if you're aware of the issue and um you
know
what's what's your thoughts on this
whole thing i mean i actually wasn't
i wasn't aware of it until i until i saw
you guys talking about it so
i mean i've i've been fortunate that i i
mean i haven't sort of experienced it
yet i've used my playstation a fair bit
i'm obviously still not a great deal
because
it hasn't been out that long and
obviously you just you know played
through the the few games we've got so
i'm kind of waiting for for more stuff
so i haven't really used uh yeah i
haven't experienced that myself but then
i was also kind of lucky
i never got it on the nintendo switch
either so i guess i'm like
oh yeah you know
sometimes i want to see how people
people we treat in their control like
i'm like oh that's my controller i put
it in a drawer i put it on a shelf and
these
people would drift are like dashing
their controllers
yeah but anyway no but jokes aside i
mean like yeah it's literally 100 agree
like you know
it is an issue like that it doesn't kind
of send the greatest message you're like
yo can you
especially right now over in lockdown
like sometimes shipping can be
hella expensive right now yes i feel
like you know because you put it in like
a decent sized box and then obviously it
also depends on like if they start
getting
a lot of these yeah i don't know what
the kind of cases if they get started
getting a lot and then like they get
backlogged with repairs
imagine if you're like a month without
your controller and you're like
[Music]
70 quid on like a brand new dual
settings
so it's it's it's definitely tough um so
yeah
they definitely try and sort of like oh
yeah address it and trying to give the
the best possible customer service
because that's ultimately what people
will remember right right no absolutely
absolutely
lord addict how how nice for you to join
us today
how are you doing so i don't know i've
been here this whole time
it's a pleasure to have you as part of
the i love podcasts
i've been here this whole time oh yeah
why are you trying to always act like
i'm late
[Laughter]
i had an inside joke of what to say but
i can't say it because it would
definitely get us in trouble
um so sir um joy conjure from the joint
dual set drift you know uh have you
heard about it do you know anybody
that's experiencing
it what's going on i don't know one
person mm-hmm no way okay
all right now let me ask you this um
because we know
nintendo similarly had the issue with
joey carter
the report's coming out and there was a
big window before even acknowledgement
right now lately i think um was it last
year
they um actually announced a new policy
where they're acknowledging it and
they're offering
both afflicted owners free repairs and
granted refunds
for private repairs and then they
formally apologize this is the first
from nintendo
but again they didn't say anything about
the what probably prompted it which was
that class action
lawsuit shout out to hogan who's got a
great great video on this whole thing
but um do you think i mean i just addict
this do you think
um they need to be it will be a
situation they won't acknowledge it
until they get pressure
from the community like more people come
up and pray like based on sony's history
as far as customer service or whatever
like what do you think about that
i mean i don't know like sony
all it's always like a weird
i don't so no one that ever knows is
knows
how someone's gonna react to something
until sony reacts to something
like like i feel like it does have to be
a widespread thing like
i don't know if for all i know they
could be fixing this stuff behind closed
doors
right you know i don't know exactly how
widespread this
is like do they have any type of number
on it um the only thing is i mean kotaku
actually themselves were experiencing it
and they were talking about their
experience with uh customer service on
sony
um and that's where they found out you
know that sony wanted them to pay for
the
you know um the shipping or whatever it
is um there's been videos there's a guy
playing destiny
it's like 3.9 million yeah thank you
thank you for the clarification thank
you sir
they sold 4 million so 3.99
but um there's been videos coming out of
obviously people but again from a
widespread
i didn't even know myself i mean i'm
kind of in eric's shoe like i didn't
even realize
i'm afraid to turn on my collars oh my
god
[Music]
i'm living i mean to be honest with you
if they're asking for people to pay for
that
that that's ridiculous like clearly that
that's
that's something wrong with your
controller and if you're asking
your customers i don't understand if
it's one or two
but it seems like it is a little bit
more widespread than just one or two
i mean yeah you you should pay for that
shipping
like it to to be honest like a
controller angle cost that much to ship
like and just to be clear microsoft like
shipped an entire console with the 360s
to try to say that and they can't they
can't do a controller
yeah i mean you could even like even if
they don't do sending you the box at the
very least let you just print out
the damn label and so you don't hear me
have to worry about that part about it
well uh just to be clear because i think
i may i just want to make sure i got it
right but again the cataclysm
he was told the jewel says drift is
covered on it
is covered underwater discovered you
will however have to pay for shipping
for your controller to a sony repair
center of course that varies based on
the number of factors including the
location and total weight of your
package
but sony apparently covers the return
shipping
no recoup on whatever you pay for that
first shipping label though
and and that's the thing like they
should be you should they should
have you print out a label at home so
that you can send it to them
right yeah and then a couple of the
return shipping is right i agree
it's just i don't know man this
i have not had the issue with my dual
sense right
but when you look at the amount of tech
in that controller
where it's the haptics astrobot shows it
well too
yeah something's liable to break right
so
and it's gen 1 it's gen 1 hardware like
gen 1 hardware
all of that stuff's coming in hot so
yeah you know it's very likely
this stuff will happen wasn't the the
the for some people there's another
issue that happens like the haptics go
so hard in certain games that
it they've actually stopped responding
for some people i don't know
how big the problem is but i've seen a
few accounts of that online so
uh you know that and these days when
that stuff happens they
you know you're going to get a
class-action lawsuit quick like very
quick and just
at least like like you guys were saying
though to push the uh
the owners they push sony in this case
to to take action
right um i have had the issue with my
switch and you know
you guys know me and how i am with my
stuff you're very meticulous you're very
careful
and i had quality pristine quality so
and
i had it with my original joy-con that
came with the system
then i got the uh the legend of zelda
ones with the d-pad
yeah same thing after a while started
happening and i'm just like okay
this is this is a real problem because i
don't i don't even play that much and
when i do play but
there'll be times i turn my console on
and it'll just
it'll it'll be on the the home screen
and it'll go it'll just automatically
just run
run the cursor all the way to the right
no and then i'll run it back
and then run it back to the right and
then i have to like take the d-pad and
like
turn it around like this like trying to
do like a like a full set like a like a
like a spinning power driver was angry
to get it to sort of reorient and even
then after a while it would come back
and do it again
so yeah it's a real problem so i don't
you know i definitely understand this
with the dual sense yeah the dual
sensors the 70 dollar controller i
yet but i really do think yeah they need
to they need to address this and
i'd be forward-facing about it i think
the way nintendo handled it up front
until they got shamed into it yeah you
know listen nintendo tried to handle it
in another way they just removed them
all entirely gave you the stand still
i was like here you go and i was hoping
that everybody purchased the standstill
console
go back and continue to purchase the one
with the joy-cons yeah i
personally love the og one the original
switch
uh i thought the joy-cons was amazing
playing a lot of the games that uh did
take advantage of it
i thought the haptic feedback in the
controller was amazing that tech is
insane it's fantastic but but what we're
seeing is
these uh phenomenal upgrades in the
control of feedback
and how we interact with our games come
with a terrible price at some points in
time
and uh this is the byproduct of that
they just really need to take advantage
of the customer's service part of it and
we know that sony has always had like a
frowny face when it came to customer
service
and i think this is a part where we can
give them that smiley face you know if
they always have that little chart it's
like the five faces
yeah and it's sad because sometimes
you know you can't count on these
companies sometimes to to
to have your best interests at heart
when it comes to returning stuff and
what have you
um but like yeah the best buy thing man
best buy as a savior
they came to my original elite
controller i did because i have
forgotten about that because i hadn't
purchased anything in best buy for a
while and i remember you guys told me
the best one
extended warranty my elite controller
the first one remember the rubber
rubber grips started coming off and
i just took it back in and they were
like oh you got the extended warranty
yeah here you go go back there grab
another one and you go ahead no
questions asked the hell out of that
yeah
i'm sorry that's the hustle like we're
not even going live like
get your peripherals accessories for
best box that's why we need a bag shout
out
shout out the best buy we need event um
but yeah like best warranty in the
business it's not even close like it's
like like
literally it could be out of the box you
used it you did everything as long as
you got purchased that warranty program
you come back they even
even if you got the receipt they even
got you all fine oh yeah we got you
go go to the back and yeah you're good
and you walk out in like
you know the quickness with a new
version of your joint like it's
it's insane but um yeah real quick super
chat then i'll go and
move on okay we have
uh dan oh we got that one hold on a
second i have to run around
give me time philly eagle with the five
dollar super chat does controller drift
occur due to playing angrily
i've never had a controller with drift
issues and i don't play angry so i'm
genuinely curious
now i mean listen i i'm the most calm
dude when i'm playing games
and nope it just happens like so it's
speaking specifically about the the
joy-con yeah yeah
it's it's a defect it's a defect and i
don't know what happened to my xbox
controller mm-hmm
i was playing destiny so much you know
going forward with the original d1
going forward so much that it was one
time i put my controller down i was like
let me run the bathroom real quick and
my
guy was already gone
i'm not gonna sit here and act like this
is an isolated incident that will happen
to xbox
yes it happens to xbox but at the same
time i just got rid of the console and
got rid of the controller because
microsoft had did me dirty with that uh
that program you know being in that
program but no no
actually you know it does happen is you
know we're interacting with new tech
this is a good
great new tech kind of stuff is going to
happen it definitely is i mean i'm sure
playing angrily in some ways
not not help does that help the
controller and expecting it
to continue to work for you yes
that we have bernard oh say with the two
pound super sack
this is this is the way xbox is king
customer service is number one
yeah that customer service is very good
yeah yeah then we got shroom kingdom
with the two dollars we chat sony acting
like an ebay seller you pay the shipping
[Laughter]
again
the legend five pound super chat if you
sell me anything and that thing is
faulty
you apologize and offer to fix that
fault for free period
what's wrong with these people yeah yeah
i don't know
and it's it's weird honestly sony's
never been the greatest it's customer
service
but if you see if you like this is like
nintendo levels of kind of like yo
i need to address this because nintendo
what they try to do with the joy-con was
like ignore it
yes though they definitely try to ignore
it they definitely try to act like they
don't know like
because we want them to just keep buying
joy-con right that's what that means
that's the nintendo way
maybe yeah maybe get a different color
check out check out the lime green model
we have down
[Laughter]
[Music]
let me see you have anything else hold
on yeah
what can you expect from a company that
allows someone to steal money from you
and then tell you that it's your fault
wow
that is kind of crazy and we got a shiny
brand new playstation 5 owner jw is a
show with the 10
super chat so sony sold the gazillion
katrina brazilian consoles
and made mazillion dollars in profit and
they can't pay for the round trip
the ultimate consumer friendly company
i'm messi right now
y'all bad about this shipping there yeah
let's see it started
tell them why you mad
then we got microwave bet size finest
five dollar super chat
you know your company is broke when they
charge you for shipping
great greatest greatness awaits fighting
right king that's
savage hey y'all bad about this shipping
man it is what it is
you know it's a lot of ridiculous though
like like
you know at least they pay for the
return shipping yeah
did you imagine they sent you an email
all right send us five dollars and we
send your controller
yeah this is a sticker you gotta control
put your hands in the air you want your
controller back
hey um like if you
were doing this and they and they ask
for you to ship the controller to them
would that l
would that like make you rise your eye
raise your eyebrow a little bit
like like to to me it doesn't it doesn't
matter at the end of the day because
like i said it's not going to cost much
to ship this but it's just like
it's weird that they want that like yeah
no it is interesting i mean i'll jump in
quick um
look i think we need there's no lawsuit
right now first so we gotta
wait and see if if this becomes more
widespread but if it does
it'll be interesting to see how they
budge and respond to it you know what
i'm saying i'm very curious to see
you know it takes a lot for somebody to
bring the deal on certain policies
so i will i am curious to see if this
becomes more widespread
and like more key influencers have the
problem then
you know we're gonna see if they move on
it but um that's there is a suit though
there is yeah there's a there's the
class action law
i'm late that's the reason why i brought
this here
i don't know sorry i did not know that i
thought they were like i thought it was
in the accumulation phase of experience
no no no no they
i don't know again i don't know the
number of cases they have but in the
lawsuit they
uh they point to a number of reddit
posts
and uh social media posts indicating the
the issue oh wow i apologize i did not
do this
oh wow okay they're trying to they're
trying to eat off of this action lawsuit
let's see
anyway it is what it is anyway
moving on that's what i got i am up
and i'm glad uh we got lord eric's for
this one
everybody talk about this for sometimes
this is last time was here um
yeah last time you were here little eric
so it was a fun show
you know i would say destiny 2 was
peaking at its time
division 2 was announced you know what
i'm saying we were hearing about all the
content the rays
then this other game this other game
came from the woodwork you know what i'm
saying
and um it was anthem it was anthem and
at the time it was a big show for us
because
we had you and at the time you had like
exclusive access you would play you had
played a lot of this stuff
and we were like yo which one like which
you feel you know that's that kind of
thing
so and here we are now 20 you know 2021
and shout out to jason schreiber he put
out the article
so it looks like yeah e ea will be
holding a meeting
to determine whether to create a new
version of the failed online game anthem
he said anthem was uh basically put out
in february 2019.
poor reviews he said there's been a
small team put together to overhaul the
game
and then i believe executive producer
christian daly
he wrote some uh big posts about all the
changes they were going to do with
anthem next or anthem 2.0
and then in december he left the anthem
team you know i'm saying as far as byway
so
this is you know the entrance from my
understanding it's um it's a clean now
that only includes about 30 people ea
will
uh the leak has come out from jason and
um this is the week
that ea will determine the fate of it
will it even continue as a franchise and
his last tweet
i believe he put out was saying that the
media the stuff is still going on
and we will probably hear the answer
next week you know what i mean
so even though this week is probably
what it's already been decided
it'll probably get to us next week so i
want to bring this to the realm um
[Music]
you know um what's the your thought
process on it
um also lord eric's should anthem be
saved
and um if so um
how could it come back so what's your
thoughts on this whole anthem situation
works
sure so i mean i feel like i mean the
first answer like shouldn't be saved
i think like i'm i'm one of those people
that i just enjoy games like regardless
right so like
every game should have its chance like i
i completely understand
in this you know in this day and age
obviously like there's a lot of games
that are coming out on the bait and like
you know people are like oh you know
we've
pre-ordered and things haven't delivered
i completely get this you know there's
that frustration i've always had a very
kind of laid-back approach to games and
that's not just that's not just because
you know i'm in a fortunate position
where i'll give be given review codes
like this was even when i was at uni i
used
to buy my game i'll buy a game i'll play
it i'm like this game's rubbish oh well
never mind i'll put on the shelf and i
go and play something i was like it's
never been too deep for me
all right so i oh and also like
sometimes some of my favorite gaming
experiences might have been from like
quote unquote rubbish games you know
i've played like there's a lot of games
that people don't like that are just
like
you know enjoy so the thing is like
anthem 100 like fails to deliver you
know
they did a there's there's a lot like
warning signs that we obviously sort of
saw
you know like now it makes sense so
there's the one thing that i've started
to
realize now is that when you start
speaking to uh
kind of developers and content create
like you know content like a head of
lord
asking an endgamer and they specifically
tried to dodge the question you're like
i should probably start worrying now
right
this is the thing but like the thing is
the the and i still stand by what i said
before like although i answered my fails
delivered on like so many levels like
the core
moment-to-moment gameplay was and is
still fun it's still
the best iron man game yeah oh thanks i
would join that yeah
raining down missiles like was super fun
yeah if the game had like genuinely if
the game had more content i would still
be playing at this stage like
the only reason i stopped playing anthem
was not you know it's not because of
like all the kind of like everyone
getting angry about it it's literally
because i was like
there's nothing for me to do like
there's no there's no
bills i was just gonna say
like out of all the games that's been in
that like destiny kind of realm
where that like evolving kind of world i
do feel like
you know anthem has has the most
potential
because you know there's so much type of
unique type of gameplay
especially raids with the type of
gameplay that that anthem has
and i think that that was the thing that
disappointed me the most was
like they they finally have a foundation
of something good but it feels like
it feels like sometimes these companies
get a little close-minded
like they make they make something and
then they don't think oh this has to be
around in a year
yeah well i think i think the problem is
because and you see this with a lot of
companies you see it in division uh you
see it even in destiny like you hear a
lot of the time
internal conflict where there'll be like
different one teams
i want to tell a story another team's
like we need to make an end game
experience and and the problem is well i
completely get it right i get
development is a big expensive like long
process so i get they don't have the
same
time that gamers do to play games but
the other thing and i don't mean this
from like an alicia's point of view but
the other
time is that a lot of the time i don't
feel like the people play
the games enough in that space you know
like you can you can play it on a
surface level
i've invested 100 hours with that that's
cool but these people you're making the
game for will invest a thousand hours
off a thousand hours right if you don't
do that and you don't play that and you
don't understand
that's that's why when you sort of see
some of these like developer talks early
on and they're like oh yeah we've got
this kind of fun gameplay experience
where you can
run strike and get like a hat for your
characters like that's not going to keep
me playing my dude
in there's a lot of that but the thing
is the thing is right right like
going forward to now to this topic is
that i would love to see anthem just
because i enjoyed the
the momentum gameplay i would love to
see it come back but i also feel like
it's a really challenging time right now
because i think
looter shooters in general are going in
a very similar direction to where like
battle royale is you know when it first
came out everyone's like
with all the craze yeah yeah and i feel
like lucy is like so much
because because so many of the recent
ones have just like undelivered like you
know models of vengeance
[Music]
even division although division two was
a fantastic sequel to number one
one of the things i feel like it
suffered from was that division two was
was a very competent game but it was
like it was it was almost like
clinically
good it was sterile it was like a really
good game but it wasn't
exciting it was just like a good game
like it's technically very good
it had loads of aspects but it wasn't
like hugely sort of exciting i feel like
a lot of the games now
you know they all do that thing where
you get to the end and they're like
right you can make a crazy build and i'm
like for what
and it's like i don't know just make it
right so they're all doing the same
thing and i think now everyone's just
like
i kind of don't want another looter like
i think people have there was that
little period of time where everyone's
like i love this because i can buy a
looter and it and it's the only game i
need to buy for the year i'm gonna play
it for the next
two years whereas now people are like i
just want to play a game finish it and
put it on my shop
no no i was just saying i hear what
you're saying and i think that um
you know just to jump in on on the
looter thing you know what i'm saying uh
obviously you know a lot of people like
you said like battle royale i
call it officially the mumble rap of
gang like everybody was doing battle
royal at one time everybody had a bar
they wanted to spit about how they could
make a
a battle royal game and i do agree that
luda shooter was the craze
at one point and let's be real you know
from a desti i gotta shout out that's
there's
one of my favorite games that you know i
think people seen companies
publishers seen the monetary gain of
having this
living breathing games as a service and
constant engagement and it was like okay
we need to make one of these two
under our house you know what i'm saying
kind of thing and i'm not saying the
anthem was definitely
100 birth out of that but i definitely
do think that you know there was some
thought process and yeah let's have
something similar
so i i hear you you know and it's one of
those things that
let's be real like outside of destiny is
not a lot of them standing
you know what i'm saying that you know
especially in the console space you know
so and even the destiny community half
the time is mad about this and that
about that
you know you know what's sad cognito
right like
the fact that destiny messes up a lot
like a lot a lot like a bunch of you
always be messing up but
like the thing that they get right is
that in-game
concept to a point right the core game
and i think that's something that the
division of the anthem
and all the other ones like it's like
they spin
all of the budget but when it comes to
the in-game content
they it's like they grow blank like one
of the things that i really
liked about the division that i wish
they would have expanded on was like the
dark zone
i felt like that was if there was
anything to get me to get that game full
time it would have been the dark zone
yeah i think they did that
in division one i think division two
lacked that whole feel of the dark zone
because division one it was okay you
just get a hell of going to dog zone
when you did go inside the dog zone you
went in with a buddy you got in you got
out you ran into a crazy team and
it turned into a moment and i think
division one had a lot of those moments
i think division two i i'm this is
that was the disconnect for me with
division two i think they started
worrying too much about raids
and didn't worry too much about the dark
zone and uh
loot epic loot i like if if you get a
golden gun and you know you get the
chatterbox and you get something like
that
it has to be a game-changing type of
stuff like if
in in in destiny if if
if you guys don't understand why destiny
is so prevalent to a lot of the destiny
players
i can tell you a quest for the uh the
whisper
you know um these things like getting
the hawk moon
uh these questions perfected
and it's it's always when you're playing
it
you say this is so bungee they would put
something like this that makes it so
daggone hard to make you quit to do the
quest
and when you actually do receive said
item
it lives up to its expectations i got to
give attic his credit
because attic literally and he's he's
lived up to this his word
he said once these consoles come yo you
know king i'm coming back to
uh console and he's been there and i've
been on and he's made it his business to
your king let's do this or king let's do
that
and these quests and these stuff it
relies on friendships and buddies right
it relies on your team
and not saying that the content itself
doesn't have to be compelling because
destiny content
is right but what makes it memorable
is the antagonist as great as the hero
is
fast the antagonist must be equal
right in stature or greater than the
heroes so the hero can overcome
said problem right and that's not what i
felt
in um anthem i felt an anthem
they had the tower part down pat
when you talk to people and you talk to
them you're like man he has presents
this looks nice and yeah you know you
fly in the sky
this looks nice but then when you
started fighting the enemies they were
generic
numbers yeah that was my issue like i
felt like
i struggled with it because let me jump
this is a good one the thing is
anthem like like uh lord eric said had
the best
feeling of the iron man sibling i've
ever think like i remember going to the
edge of fort tarsus
and you just jump off into the air and
you into the sky and you jet pack it
is one of the most amazing feelings i
ever felt i didn't like that it was
limited flying there
and i always thought that like once the
game got
settled and the rings were put out that
like
a ray boss and anthem would be the most
epic epic
right and that i was disappointed like
you said it best with the
i felt their enemy types were too
generic i liked the combo the priming
i like the classes were unique the
colossus the the storm guy
like they got that down you know what
i'm saying gunplay for the most part was
good
and like i said the aerial aspect but i
just feel like
they me like the enemies just felt i
didn't care i didn't fear them i didn't
really care about them
and one thing like it's like when you
play destiny and you face like an oryx
or you face a rhythm
right you like yo this is a boss we got
to get together to
to come up and that's the thing people
don't realize that's the hook of destiny
even attic has said his best like when
destiny has a good rate he's there
like with destiny that raised that
cooperative mechanic
to team together to fight something
that's that's end game content
that's what keeps you coming back unique
luke that kind of stuff
and it just seemed that they couldn't
remember they kept saying the cataclysm
watch out for the cataclysm y'all know
remember cataclysm is coming
and then we raise yeah right all right
good alex
it was just a reinstitute just like came
out as little like it was like a basic
story yeah it was a basic style
i was like you know and i was expected
to fight boom bastard creatures but
we're all flying could you imagine
like they they had the template right
there they just they didn't
execute you know i said i was just like
oh but anyway i just want to get that
off
that's the internal struggle that eric's
is talking about
where somebody wants to give you a great
lore
and great content if somebody wants to
give you great end game
i don't think see it goes back to ea
right i think it goes back to the parent
company right
and the level of investment that you
must
uh undertake for these titles you must
have a significant amount of investment
and fortitude
to see it through because like sovereign
likes to say
you can either you know snatch a victory
from the
jaws of defeat or you can snag defeat
from the jaws of victory
very easy in this business but you must
have the fortitude to wish
to stand there and fight through it
and i don't think if you're having this
call two to three years in on your game
yeah no your road map should have been
this is a 10-year game
we're gonna stick our feet in the sand
and we're gonna fight as hard as we
possibly can to keep our core base and
to grow it from the internal
right and let it spread out through the
word of mouth and you can
only do that through compelling gameplay
and getting these people to talk about
it
now i do feel that
and i told people that it was going to
be doa right i'm like i'm not going to
buy you this
words he called it you called it right i
i didn't feel that it had a place
because when you taking college courses
you can take two majors
you can't take three right and those two
majors was
destiny and division you didn't have
space for it right
you've got you've got to be so
compelling right to take over but
i know where you're going yeah but i
think it can live
if they're willing to swallow their
pride and throw it in one of these
services
or put it on their ea access so ea's
already engaged
this yeah you know you
can live to be honest with you king
it would take a drastic overhaul of that
game to get players to try to
come back to it we've seen no man's sky
yeah but that that was that was an
independent developer determined to
correct their mistakes
like and i'm not saying that you know
they can't correct their mistakes like
but i'm saying uh you you know hello
what's what was that developing was it
yeah games
yeah i'm saying hello games wasn't
working isn't working on dragon age
on the other side of the studio i mean
that
like ea's like yo man
okay we failed like we got dragon age
over here look
let's just pull the plug really playing
it right now
affiliate what you're saying right and
and just to contact
that one part that what you're saying is
okay so if you if you admit it failed
right
and this is where you can snatch victory
from the jaws of the feet
throw it inside game pass throw it aside
yeah yeah what i'm saying because
though because it's in there yeah yeah
but here's my thing all right let's
let's jump in i'm sorry i'm going to
give it to you i know we have trouble
oh the thing i have to say is that let's
just say
you give it now uh xbox series x or
playstation 5 optimization patch
right because i'm telling y'all right
now i play anthem on pc
first right that game is the most
beautiful it's the most demanding but
it's the most
beautiful looking game i have ever
played
like that game looks phenomenal as a
looter when you like i said you have
four tosses you jump off
and you just man it's iron man the game
you tony starks out here for real just
my only thing is okay let's say you do
that you offer it
free you cannot charge anybody for this
at this point because the games
the game's morale it it's already cache
is already low
you say hey this is a free update you
guys
right four dollars you know something
right you you get you get people in
there
you got game pass just to get the gauge
to check it out right
and you just use this as a gauge to then
now once people start coming back
then you can start setting up maybe a
potential at them two or whatever
whatever down the road i think the
potential is still there
for it to live but to king's point you
know it's the boardroom
and if if if the ballroom is like
nah fam you know that's the attic's
point yeah
to your point you know if they like not
fam we we gave you a run or whatever
whatever
it's just sad i just i just hope it gets
i'm with eric's i'm i'm i i don't want
any game to die
you know i i always will because i do
feel like anthem has
the most you know it has a lot of
potential yeah i do i do agree with you
guys on that
yeah but uh let me get uh the
single-player selfish experience
perspective
um i am very curious about you with this
let me get this get they have the living
flame
two dollars super chat i'd rather uh let
next come out and fail then
axe it right yeah um when you finish
that i want to say something real quick
before you go so
okay uh then we have andy crawley with
the ten dollars of a chat it was either
this is a daytona i think i chose
wisely salute
and we have the rubber knob hit the ten
dollars in the chat
not only am i a girl's best friend i'm
also a bit of a casanova happy
valentine's day to all the ladies of the
realm
bushes be shaking around the world today
wow
of course
i think the biggest issue in this
industry
is trend chasing of course i i think
these companies
they want to build something off what's
hot but they don't want to actually
think about building something around
what's up the problem about building
something around what's hot is that by
the time you come to
yeah it's not hot anymore where they
don't take initial like i'm not saying
they don't take initial thought but
i'm saying that sometimes they rush it
to get it out as fast as they can
right by the time it's not unique
and the one that you you you built it
because of like you know let's say
destiny although you know
the destiny definitely spawned these
anthems these divisions
at least the concept yeah well by the
time they came out
destiny at its height you got to do
something different and better
to get destiny's people off destiny
because trust me i got like i got like
50 days in that something different well
i felt they were i felt it was different
i felt that like i said they were doing
something in the vertical space that was
just different but
if the content isn't there yeah i agree
then it doesn't matter all that's really
when is the worst time in destiny
you're right let's get some super chat
you got everything yeah yeah one more
victorian five dollars super chat uh
what if with the ea partnership xbox is
able to finance an ea title exclusively
for game pass like a titanfall 3 or a
titan fault like game yeah
yeah i don't know i tried that the first
time yeah didn't own the ip
that's not a route that we want us to go
into the point i want you to go into
places where
you own the ip you're not licensing
you're not holding on this is a new
regime they're about ownership
they need their content they don't need
their content leaving going anywhere
else
so i don't think that's a viable option
at all
and as as a matter of fact i don't think
even sony is entertaining those type of
ideas at this point in time
they're looking for acquisitions they
need ownership they understand that the
platforms
need to be viable because going forward
you
you want to be able to turn on your box
because you can only get this here
you don't go to burger king to go get a
big mac you understand you want a big
mac you take yourself to mcdonald's you
want a whopper you go to burger king
that's plus
they both can exist right but no no more
renting
rent and plus king like we've seen over
and over again
like you know not necessarily your sony
but we've seen
you know trusting other people to make
your brand yeah hurts you in the long
run because then you have the rises
they're not getting sequels you have the
quantum breaks that never get sequels
yep the sunset overdrive now obviously
this is on microsoft two for not funding
those
but let's say they wanted they wanted to
make a rise too but they couldn't
right so what games did they do they did
sunset
overdrive and look at this now what can
happen
sunset overdrive two can be on
playstation yeah that's good that's
gonna be crazy what i have you know
you know when that game does come out
for all those sunset overdrive people
that purchase it
microsoft put themselves in a bad
position by not owning the ip
i feel like no more you know i agree i'm
with you and as much as i'm peter
moore's my guy
you know that was the only thing that i
i missed out on um
i felt like they relied too much on
those third-party deals
you're in the main door and i'm saying
mute yourself because you're talking to
the whole crew yeah
[Music]
what do you think single players have
selfish experience
um what i think is funny is different
what you guys think um
i think i want anthem to come back oh
i say not in that form i mean back to
what you guys have been talking about
with this is a crowded space and
uh destiny kind of has a chokehold on it
right now destiny
they they you know they went through the
highs and lows they know what it takes
to have to maintain a game of this size
and magnitude
and even knowing that they still trip up
like
you guys they're not they're never
making you happy a hundred percent
satisfaction
you have to be willing to to ride that
game out
it's highs and lows and all right and
that is a commitment
that you know as big as gay is it they
it doesn't seem like they
want to make um so
but what i'd like about anthem right
when i played anthem i
i didn't purchase it but but uh boston
purchased it so i had access to it yeah
so for my thing as like the the
the game clan anthem felt so good the
flying felt so good
and and the story though weird and sort
of abstract this anthem of creation and
the wall protecting humanity
do remove that from the lunar shooter
right
because you're already trying to get
into a genre that's saturated that you
that you
realize it's an uphill battle right take
that stuff
and go back to making a third person
action game whether it be co-op
multiplayer make up
create a cohesive world around anthem
and make a fantastic aaa third-person
action game
make you know create you know go towards
making a trilogy or something like are
you implying that bioware act like
bioware are you
are you precisely not even right
because bioware today isn't quite by the
bioware that it was before but i would
say at this point
they're at least better equipped to give
you a third person action game with rpg
elements
than they are to give you a little
shooter that was one of the things we
always talked about from the beginning
is like
i don't mind uh i don't mind developers
going out of their comfort zone and
trying something new the problem with is
like addict uh alluded to is just the
fact that you're you're
you're trying to do you're trying to do
a me too in a space that's already
saturated
with games that are despite the question
or something hard yes put your arm in
something for salt
right now imagine an anthem game this is
a third-person action game
a four-player multiplayer right but it's
it's a straight-up game it's a 20-hour
campaign
uh you know amazing story amazing boss
fights and that is it and then you have
a sequel
like making a living game is something
that you have to know
exactly what you're getting into when
you do it and being different for the
sake of different doesn't work
and then so coming back with a 2.0 that
is
a mirror image of destiny doesn't work
either like it just doesn't work
now to me i i like what anthem brings to
the table
but give me turn it into something else
that's viable
right and i guarantee you and they've
already seen that they're just thinking
with them about
oh not making single-player experiences
they're already seeing that's in the
bushes
they've already seen they're already
going to get us with the mastermind
collection they know
where their strengths lie go back
yo i have never seen this uniformity for
solve like this this is crazy
exciting it's funny because you would
think you would think i would yeah i
would despise
the game like this right now yeah i'm
shocked by this but at the moment it's
like you said when you hit
the edge of sport tarzan you jump off
and start flying i was like oh
let's go let's go until your point is
off to your points off
and kid can relate and alex could relate
the first time we
saw anthem debut at e3 stage
we kind of we didn't think it was a
lunar shooter we no necessarily like it
felt like they were talking to each
other
it was it was this cooperative storyline
and then we're thinking bioware we're
thinking
player choice we're thinking all that i
i feel you
we're thinking like third person action
we got
that other stuff yeah we got that and
and i think like to average this point i
think the moment-to-moment game play
is fun but when you don't have the
content and when the loop
isn't the gameplay could be fun but the
the key to a lunar shooter is the loop
is the loop it's the willingness to be
coming back for however many hours
and it didn't have that and i just think
what if you would
able to just consolidate that into a
more into a smaller package that's more
focused that you create a real world and
story around this type of gameplay
who's not going to gravitate to that
yeah yeah
i think that's kind of interesting i
think that's kind of where the this
genre is
well at least though the newer ones in
this space they're trying to do to a
degree not to say they are the the
perfect ones but when you look at like
what the developers have said for uh
outright
game that you can complete that service
yeah that's
not to cut you errors but you wanted
something too because
that's what i like what outriders is
doing they're saying yo bro we're not
doing that games as a service
thing over here we're this and this
narrative cooperative continue
because you you're on your back it's
interesting because they're because
they're in a they're in a difficult
space because
developers are saying that but people
are still not listening because even
though
i know i know it was not uh you know it
didn't end up being being great but even
they said before we are not a game as a
service but everyone went assuming it's
a game as a service
and the pro so like because everyone's
so conditioned they're i don't think
there have been enough enough games
outside of say like borderlands
yes uh correct that's kind of it's in
that space that are not a game as a
service and i think people
need to kind of have that adjustment
period but the other thing i feel like
yeah i definitely definitely agree to
your point i feel like it needs to be
more of a contained experience that you
can complete in 20 hours
and if what if you want to give someone
an endgame style experience they use
them all right it's a 20 hour campaign
and there is a couple of dungeons there
is something
that is akin to a raid it is not going
to be expanded beyond this point but
you've got something to chase what these
games need to do and they can do it if
they make it like that
because i get that they can't it's hard
to do something something like destiny
these games
need to stop balancing things to help
right now i mean
again like when i've played for 60 hours
and i've got like
the the 5.0 bazooka that's like the
legendary weapon that basically leveled
an entire army before
and i fire it and does 10 damage i'm
like
facts i loved about borderlands until
they started knocking it i
literally could make a build where i
could i could kill a boss in three
bullets and i'm like this is
cool because like destiny like i've i've
fallen back oryx i've fought back
i'm so behind in destiny i don't even
know the names these guys
different bosses right and i'm supposed
to be this legendary guardian
and i'm still i'm still shooting things
i'm just like why i i get it i know that
this is important
so i get that but like give me some
games you want to film
yeah like you look at diablo you can
wade through a dungeon just like one
type of everything like i want to have
those broken builds
right and a couple couple of games
recently
look at like um a game that's not even
supposed to be this game goes to
tsushima when it came out
with the
because then also as you say like if you
guys like you know you guys are super
invested in destiny it's hard to
buy another game like that when you are
living in very honestly i agree with
that and that's
it's funny that's my beef with destiny
right watching
exactly they're about to kill me now no
but my beef destiny is that the core
gameplay of destiny and the loop and the
and and the loop of the you know the
carrot on the stick the new weapons is
that part i think it's great but it
isn't for me
if it was separate from a core 25-hour
campaign experience that they kind of
fleshed out the world fleshed out the
characters fleshed out the story
destiny tries to do both and i think in
that regard the story kind of falls back
just that
fact that's the story falls behind to
the actual noodle shooter part about it
if they had both man i didn't no i could
be
just to the story stuff but i'd be in i
listen you guys are on fire
all making great points i think eric's
what you said in reference to like uh
outright as a borderlands
just just know who you are don't say
that you're this destiny killer
and you're going to be this game what if
they stop saying that yeah please stop
saying
some of these marketing teams we you
know we see the fans and we like
billions of dollars yeah i'm gonna keep
it a buck i think the
the the game that can challenge destiny
in that realm
is the one that i'm talking about that
can do both of those things well right
and
on a bigger scale on a bigger scale
right but it almost feels like bungees
are the ones but that's the situation
yeah and that's the thing
the problem is they have the best gun
play in gaming
and the weber design team and the
marketing team is phenomenal we do have
the issues but
i gotta let you finish dinner the
problem with that is like
to make a game like that it requires a
lot of
trial and error and bungie
has been doing it enough and they
because it's their only game
oh you know obviously they have another
one but you know what i'm talking about
so they're getting all of this data
before anyone else really does
so like they're in the best position by
far
okay people don't like this why justice
like because the other ones aren't
they're getting that but they're not
getting that because
clearly we it's been a while since we've
seen anything out of the division
right uh you know anthem might be dead
next week
so they're not getting this information
and they're not
correcting the mistakes to actually push
the game forward
and yeah and marvel is just finished
yeah maul's another one yeah i mean he
made a good point the last point
we'll move on is just that um destiny
has been very fortunate
to be able to survive with the hiccups
and learn on the fly and then
the thing i think that the gate this is
the last point i think that the other
companies do need to learn from lesney
division wasn't i think a problem was
they weren't transparent
with their community when as far as
taking feedback
right and i've seen a lot of the top you
know
division content creators express their
frustration
like these are issues we've been having
for so long and you guys have not
addressed
said issue you know what i'm saying and
when it becomes a dictatorship and
you're just talking to your basic you're
not
listening to their needs then you have a
situation where you have like shout out
to marco styles like he was the biggest
division content creator i knew and then
all of a sudden he's not got destiny
content created now you know what i'm
saying so it's like you see these shifts
and then
with anthem i gotta shout out slow-mo in
the chat like
another issue was and you made it a
point too alex
the loot like you do some hard content
you want to feel like a boss you don't
want no rocket launcher shooting five
damage
you want something that makes you feel
uniquely like a
you know what i'm saying so the whole
didn't get anything i didn't you didn't
get that feeling
the guns felt generic the powers were
dope
the priming and the combination with
synergy which your team felt though
but the actual loot was not
it to me as well as the enemy thing so
they would need to address those two
things
and then to solve point maybe they just
jump out the lane and say yo
we're this four-player cooperative
narrative thing
that will give you in pieces and it's a
finite experience
and then when you're ready to drop one's
mass effect
sounds like massive it's not like four
player fast effects but yeah
i wouldn't i mean i said one to four
player not for that straight up four
then we'll finish up the last topic with
attic um any super chat still did we
miss anything we could be good ah we
have
wait a minute christopher no that's how
come your name isn't in green
yeah that's weird i don't know i'm just
it's just kind of strange because i
could have sworn christopher hart during
the round
no i don't think he was i don't think he
was i think he should i think you should
since you're always on my time
i think you should be in green i would
agree with that yeah
you're always here i respect your your
playstation hustle
i really think your name should be angry
i really do honestly because
it shows that you know you're behind the
realm because you are because i support
you more than those fake generals over
there
they're the other playstation separate
yourself from those weirdos chris
anyway i'm moving on from king being
messy
lord addict i thought this was a good
topic with uh
with you and lord alex in the realm this
is you man what's up with kingdom hearts
what's going on explain to me
this is intricate this so first off all
you know this is a two-part question
this is a two-part topic
the first part is you know kingdom
hearts has never been on pc up until
recently it's going to epic game store
uh those of you know i i'm a huge fan of
the kingdom hearts franchise
it's second it looks like epic pulled up
against
did they drop the millions i i don't
know what they did but they did
something
not only did they do something but they
they have they have
annoyed everyone what's going on
is this a big issue like in the
community it's an exclusive
epic game so now
the reason it's bad is because this is
kingdom hearts this is something people
never expected to be on pc people gave
up
i mean look how many it's been on xbox
before it went on pc so people
never expected this game to be on pc
obviously you have a lot of steam
you know fans that they love rightfully
so they like
all their stuff in one platform but they
don't like when they have to go out
of their way and buy something from uh
another company because then
they it it splits their library up right
so
you know imagine being a huge fan of
kingdom hearts you haven't played it
since the original because you've been
on pc for the past like
decades and you get on twitter and you
say oh
kingdom hearts yes and you get on there
it's
only the epic story i gotta back you up
because i don't you're
educating me i know nothing about
kingdom hearts shout out to macho
channel lords gaming down there in the
building he is the biggest kingdom
hearts fan i know next to you
all right so you're saying the kingdom
hearts
is exclusively the pc that means you
can't get it on playstation you can't
get it on xbox like
no what's going on pc it's exclusive
like i'm confused you can't get it on
steam you can't get it oh
you mean it's not going to the steam
store epic epic store pulled up
and they're i don't know what they pay
for like the port or anything or
they just paid for exclusivity like yo
we we hear rumors that you want to make
uh
so they drop the bag so that the pc
community they gotta bend the knee
and go over the epic stuff if they want
to partake
in said for any kingdom hearts game
because that's what's going on
so steve never had it it's what you see
steam has never had any of the kingdom
hearts games oh wow wow
they're getting all of them now like
epic is getting all the kingdom hearts
wow so if you if you if you're a pc
gamer and you like you know kingdom
hearts three just k
i don't know if kingdom hearts three is
coming no always coming but it's it's
a 59.99 purchase yeah
that's besides the point
i can't i can't and so is the the rhythm
game they're really good
i can't tell epic what the charge for
their game
not epic i can't tell square enix but i
i'm just like
i'm just sitting here thinking first off
in case you guys noticed your man is for
the epic movement
i'm definitely for i know i understand
why people don't like it but i'm for it
so we're going to keep going
watch the world burn yeah watch the
world
you know all i know is if i was a steam
primary user i'd be a little upset right
now
but isn't it just another launcher like
it's just a launcher you just
launch it and then you have it yeah it's
just splitting up with you know what i'm
saying
yeah you're live eric's ready to jump in
he said this is what he's saying
right i like before anyone like in chat
pops up i understand why people don't
like
epic game store but like for me i'm just
like playing on steam and playing on
epic and playing on new play and playing
on origin
is no different and on my xbox on my
playstation
it is just like i get it they're like oh
but then they admire your nato like it
hasn't got a friends list or hasn't i'm
sorry right but like
the the consoles that have had the good
trophy frenzy system have been xbox and
playstation that's where i
hear about my trophies my xbox okay i
get it if you've been for a long time
maybe you care about your trophies i
personally don't but on pc i'm just like
it's like having four different consoles
yeah
so like i'm just like i don't know what
the fuss is
and i'm just like i mean this this is
where everyone's always gonna get angry
at me but i'm just like look right
i'm just gonna boot up whatever i do to
play my damn game oh so
so wait wait so are you implying that
you just go where the games are if
there's
if if like like the console user is
something that we've been used to
that if the game was exclusively on that
platform right we would just go to the
game so is
eric's implied that pc gamers should
just go to where the games are and just
fire up the epic star launcher
even these games are on the same damn
platform because it's not even like you
have to buy a 500
new pcs or play that would be different
if they were like oh no you have to buy
it on mac oh yeah you got to play it
exclusively
you could only play exclusively on
nvidia graphics
did i feel you you buy a new thousand
pound pc
you go i get you but this is literally
you need to go on you need to go on
google type epic game store download
download it click install
and you're playing
[Music]
[Laughter]
please keep that away from me
he separated himself from that quick i'm
somebody that watches anime right i'm a
nintendo guy right i love this kind of
stuff right but like when you're when
you're
playing this moment right and it's like
my dude's on the floor i'm about to save
him my guy goofy's like uh-huh
i'm with you if i want to watch disney
i'll watch disney
it's not that simple
i know there's a lot of people that hate
kingdom hearts but i'm curious in the
chat
put a one if you like kingdom hearts put
a two if you don't like kingdom hearts
and put a three if
so i just like that see eric's chance to
sing that's what disconnected me
from it because i was just like okay so
why are they here
i didn't understand i was like how are
they intricate
[Laughter]
we're not even talking about whether the
game's good or not
hijacked my puppet
when you're when you're uh when you're
kingdom hearts fans they're like no no
you need to try the game right they try
and sell it to you the most convoluted
the way they're like no no you couldn't
possibly play one first you must start
with alpha remix then go to three then
you're gonna go backwards to two
then you're like you play one and then
you've got five point five
then you've gotta play the alpha
ultimate version before you can even
touch three
you've gotta go back and play number one
again but then you've gotta play in
black and white because it doesn't make
sense
you want to play the game and just like
no you know what goofy i'm just going to
get
down on disney plus watch her watch a
disney movie
and i've got disney plus over here
yo attic is about to cancel eric's now
alec is disgusted this is his franchise
explain to us real quick about pastor
king why this is so
important as far as the franchise defend
the honor of kingdom hearts so that we
know
what we need to slander is wrong but we
do it
but i'm not going to tell you guys
whether or not to play as goofy all
right
i can play goofy if i want to you guys
look look at the end of the day it's
it's something up here
i will admit like a part of it is
nostalgia with me like
i've played this game since i was like
12 or 13. since he was a young
okay but but see i still enjoy it like
but the thing is
like i won't be i don't hide stuff if i
like for a lot of people know i was
disappointed with kingdom hearts three
like i'm not gonna sit here just blindly
defend something
if you don't like it don't play it's
just like how i do console war stuff
if you do not like the console don't
play it just the same thing with this
right because
you'd be surprised there's an army you
people out there
haters it's like you can't you can't
enjoy that we like playing as goofy and
donald you
you you insist that it ends you want our
heads on a platter
it's just funny man i mean it is
definitely
listen all jokes inside it it is a very
it's a huge following
huge following that game they're super
on twitter and say that
yes super passionate especially for you
especially go do it go do it
let's get kicked but i'm curious bro i'm
kidding so i'm like wait yeah
pc is for work so i don't care what epic
store does
okay i got it on my xbox it don't matter
where it goes because i'm not going
there anyway do you not sympathize with
the pc community though
i don't care about their feelings i
don't care at all
i don't care if you upset that it's on
steam or it's on epic
i don't care i don't it doesn't bother
it doesn't push my needle no place
because i'm a game pass that's where
it's at
hey news flash is it gameplay
that's where i play it that's where you
at and you know what i got game pass for
damn near forever
so i don't care i can maintain a service
guys
so i don't i don't i don't i don't care
god bless
more people get a chance to play it and
if you're in steam and you just don't
want to go to another browser or another
launcher or whatever
why do you got a pc for it if you like
the game
it should be no barriers to allow you to
play the game
you don't have to buy nothing else you
just got to go over there and launch it
that's it
you know what's funny king like a lot of
the pc people and i talked to
about reasons to come over the pc
platform yeah the number one thing they
say is it's an open platform so you're
not held
accountable to just one person but then
that same person would be like why isn't
it on steam brah
like why they don't say that i don't
know
it's very very sensitive there solve
your feelings on
on uh kingdom hearts man
um you know more power to the kingdom
hearts franchise announced that to
confuse millions of more people
on the pc problem are you implying that
the story is convoluted sir
a bit just a little bit and this is i
listen my thing with ken hearts is like
this should be you know putting final
fantasy characters
with disney characters should be a
guaranteed home run
guaranteed right and on the surface it
is because you see those characters
getting oh wow this is amazing like a
young kid couldn't look at that like
well i want this i don't know what it is
but i want it
but i just don't understand why the
story has to be so
convoluted because it to me it could
sell
triple what itself you know just just by
making it like a streamlined more
direct story and wow
that this was about epic games
now we're blasting you this is gonna
happen you knew this is gonna happen
yeah i just i that's that's weirdo
energy like king said this little energy
that you have this beef
with this launcher and just like you
don't want to give i understand you
don't want to give tim
don't give tim screen any money i get it
but you know you have a million other
places to play these games if you don't
want to play more they don't want to get
twin seating money but you know they got
no problem going there getting all the
free games that they give out
oh they're for sure yeah listen i have
like what 30 free epic game still games
so i have no beef with tim's we need to
go right ahead
it is what it is it is it is what it is
but it's just like i
i don't i don't know i mean i said man
3.99
but i think i mean shout out to them
because i know this is going to be
lucrative for them right they're the
only place to get these
these games that have never been on pc
correct um
so yeah good on them good on them like i
said my final thing yeah man it is
i was surprised i knew nothing of it
when i brought it to the table um
yeah you know the pc community is very i
mean i look i get it steam is big it's
popular
they have a lot of features from a
feature set that this you know the pc
community love
and they want that to be you know one
unified system
but hey you know if i always tell people
this like people like oh i don't like
what they should do and like
how is epic supposed to compete as a
launcher right
you gotta kind of stroll on and bring
people over exclusive content
right and then they got the bag they're
doing it you know so for us in the
console space we're used to that
if it's exclusive on xbox or exclusive
on playstation or nintendo
guess what we got to go pick up that
platform if we truly love these games if
you love kingdom hearts
get the epic store launcher it'll be
unless i'll do what kings say you're so
resistant
girl's in you got game pass you got all
this stuff where these things act you
know it's on you
if you truly love the games you know
it's the difference between loving the
games and the platform and
to me the game's always going to be
number one so that's where i'm at with
it uh let's
get six layer i think oh they said we
checked me best and then we were looking
at that five dollars uh egs wouldn't
even still exist if i didn't buy
exclusives it's more than just a
launcher
issue if pc isn't your lane that's fine
no i feel you i mean look it means more
i get you sir you know what i'm saying
but my thing is
again if they're trying to compete
right with steam which is this we all
know steve is this
just you know this beast you know what
i'm saying in the room that's been
dominant in this space
and you're trying to compete what else
can you do but buy
content that you know what you know is
going to make people want to come to
your platform
so i i get to hustle i can't get mad at
it you know i understand it's a steam if
you're a steam fan
i can understand you're being annoyed
like damn i gotta go get that joint over
there
but if you're a kingdom hearts man you
not gonna play the new kingdom hearts
yeah what i'm saying
you know what's funny about this is that
when steam first came
out right the the same argument happened
with steam they're like
i don't want this on my pc why why do i
have to have this drm well
do you want to play half-life 2 yeah
then you better get this deal all right
and my thing is is now god for steam to
step up their game like that makes it
better for the consumer like at the end
of the day like yo these dudes is out
here
they get you you can't be complacent
just because you're the market leader
because these dudes is out here you know
when i care about steam and epic and all
that stuff
when they're in game pass
[Laughter]
all this goofy talk y'all i don't want
to play it over here
it doesn't do it's nothing this is the
funny thing to like
this to me for a lot of people i would
be honestly just to have another archive
for the game if you're a kingdom hearts
fan
you've played those games right now
you're
a brand new pc owner you have a high end
pc you want to have it
cool i you know that that beef with
with epic and and it's a launcher
it does not make any any sense to me
[Music]
they're whatsoever because they have
options and it's not it's not like it's
you know what bishop we all do it's not
like it's this bow tie player
type game is it is it like no isn't it
old single player so it's not like you
need a friends list in this robust
friendship
to play kingdom hearts like what are you
doing why are you worrying about
chatting to people and you listening to
the story
yeah and the story is very convoluted so
you must pay attention
exactly not only is it convoluted you
got in a certain order
anyway that's just me i i just i feel
for you guys
you know steve lovers i apologize if i'm
coming off disrespectful
i do say this though i understand if
y'all having this real problem
and it's hurting you and it's killing
you
download gamepad
and make sure that you can play all your
kingdom hearts game in one place and you
can jump from scene to scene story to
story and make sure that game pass is
the one place
it it's funny i'm i'm on the polygon
article about it right
first comment in the comment section is
no steam no purchase
yo they ride and die seriously pc
bastard race
ride right you know i i have to put my
hands off to them because
like at least they they they stand
behind they word like yeah they don't
buy it
they like oh it's not on steam oh we're
going we're going to make it
regret i want to see how long that works
for a game that they love
they yeah when the game you loves comes
out an epic story
it's easy to play and you know okay you
know what this is this is where it's
going to get really
nasty and disgusting being that that
sony playstation
is the sony is embedded epic right
and and i'm telling you they're working
with stuff in the background and their
games go to pc
and they start launching day and date pc
vegas if they come over there
the epic the ps4 magazine and in epic
store day and date
you can get over there you can play god
of war ragnarok
day and day in the epic store and i want
to see at the bottom if you say no steam
i get it but it's the stuff what is the
game you love
the it's i've seen gamers bending me bad
times all that pickity stuff stops
so we'll we'll see anyway exactly
let's get up out of here man full new
ilp
pole it will be going up actually it is
live
right now if you check it out it is live
on lords of gaming.net so please come
check that out man
so we're gonna get into it with the esa
planning an all digital event for 2021.
what do you think
should happen with e3's future in 2022
post
pandemic the choices are a e3
is no longer needed or valued as it once
was
beginning of the end b
e3 should return and reconcile terms
with sony and all who left
c a new challenger should arise to
replace e3
as the new defacto convention or d
i don't care i'm just tired of 100
companies think they worthy if they own
e3 like event
shout out to all the lords in the realm
and of course
my brother lord eric's gaming the homie
much love from across the palm where can
the five people find you
huh kingdom hearts
little brother where can the five people
find you man what you got going on
thank you very obviously guys it's it's
always a blast coming honestly it's been
great to hang out with you guys as well
uh thank you very much having me you can
find me over on the eric's gaming
channel
uh you can find my twitter alex or you
can find me over on video games if you
want to get some uh
some games and some games whoa get the
games again love what you're doing
you want to become a monster hunter
expert man
i mean the coverage we've been following
a long time brother and uh i had to say
it loudly
i'm always believing giving people that
rose white spelling not only he's one of
the
best content creators in the game as a
man
this guy is a real dude you know what
i'm saying and i really gotta respect
you because
you know we've had a lot of
conversations off air and stuff like
that and then
during pre-pandemic you know always to
stop what he's doing
so humble you mean it's rare to see that
you know i'm saying
me and easy had a joke of like there's
certain content creators that when they
get to a certain level
it's like oh let me see how many
subscribers you have before i can
respond to you
you know what i'm saying alex is the
realest
dude man so salute to you salute to the
team 2-6
vessel paradise i love what you're doing
i love what you got going on with video
games you know i'm about the fitness
you know what i'm saying we got to get
our games in we got to do that we got to
stay healthy
i love that new evolution that you got
going on and you've been killing it man
the production values keep doing what
you're doing it's always an
honor to have you in the realm i want to
let you hear that before we move on man
absolute salute lord addict conveniently
showing up to work late
[Laughter]
what's going on there we go people find
you
well you can follow me on twitter at
lord addict iop you can find me on
uh youtube at gaming addict uh you can
also find me on twitter
completely 100 saying that i was not
late today on iop
i was just being very quiet
definitely uh appreciate you coming on
eric sorry sorry i was late
i can't i look way when i've addressed
someone uh directly i i can't i can't
live and i can't lie you know
but you're alive
oh story before he turned up
[Laughter]
all i know is i was here but you know it
is what it is i i'll definitely be here
next week
on time like i was this week and you
know
one thing i want to appreciate for
coming on and you know
it's like cognito said you're you're one
of the few people you came on here
when we had like a thousand subs
like you know what we had like when we
had our friends in the in the chat man
it wasn't even like it wasn't even you
know what went as bad as when you're
when there's like 15 and we're five of
them
facts i'm watching them right now yeah
you'll be like yo why you ain't showing
up to the podcast this week so i didn't
see you in the chat
[Music]
it was that real that's why i always
shot him out because um again
you know no ego involved he's always
showed us love he's always giving us
tips
i think that's that's right that's a
common thing no that's extremely
rare that's right we gotta celebrate it
because you know we're we're still a
gaming family
and he always pushes your city one thing
i say as a content creator you know one
of the humbling things you say yo cog
i like what you guys got going you know
saying to hear it from you
that definitely meant so much so salute
yeah and i i always think it's like you
know
when people get what they want the fame
the money that's when their real person
personality shows
facts that's why i respect iraq's
because like he got he didn't change he
you know
he got the success on youtube and he'd
be like yo
these people hit me up you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna go something man
i ain't going i don't want to go about
that that tax that get
to get ready you see that they seated it
when he didn't have money he doesn't
like kingdom hearts
there ain't no reason to save kingdom
hearts because kingdom hearts booming
yeah but just to echo uh cogs sediments
and um
and alexander myths man the first time i
met eric's uh
and i think i always been arrested 2017
e3 were walking
walking down from the uh convention
center and i'm like god
the beard the beard the beard he's got
the beard the guy with the theater
he got with the beard and he and
literally like cog just ran up to him
and
and and eric's again so inviting so like
just welcoming just him sex is moving
around yeah
six gave us a hug and you know like yeah
you guys are
and it and it's it's so true like you
know
you know listen when you talk about
youtube fame and twitter thing you know
there's a level of faith sure that said
like
you know just remember who you are where
you come from
and some people don't do that um and i'm
and i'm but i'm glad to say man that you
you really like from the very beginning
just showed us a lot of love very humble
hard-working and that's that's kind of
what we aspire to as well so
thank you so much for coming out with us
oh
[Music]
session that you
[Music]
look he tried it though i gotta get i i
was in a
fire team with some i could say it yeah
that destined to lose so he did try
he just doesn't want to lose his soul to
the guy yeah and that's part of it
that's part of my before there's like i
know
the loop even though i have all the
beasts with it but the loop
it makes me mad yeah fair enough
lord king what's going on where can i
find people
first of all i want to thank every last
person that uh showed up
and to rock out with us for this long
extended period of time
i do appreciate everything i do
appreciate the likes i do
appreciate the dislikes uh i do
appreciate the comments in the chat even
though i joke around and say if any
color i don't see it
you know but um i appreciate alex
uh little known fact i was watching him
on vg24
facts i told like i had to [ __ ] he was
like my go-to like where's sir bro
oh yeah what i need to know for
literally you were the only person i
didn't i didn't watch
kakis or anybody like that at that point
in time
um and you were literally my 100 go-to
right so then when he was like he's
having you on the show i was fanboying
out bro
oh man you know like yeah man this is a
moment because i i don't know how many
people we had
you know followers i don't know way
smaller
you know and i'm like oh my god this is
amazing
and then i'm at e3 and i'm walking with
monkey and
and and gary and um and i i forgot who
else and we're talking
and you yell like yo king classic moment
and i turned my head i said
oh snappers
[Laughter]
cause
he's taller and bigger than i thought
yeah
you know because i'm a tall dude i gave
him a hug and i'm like oh man what's
going on then we chopped it up right
there
when you talking about a real person
salute on your million brother
if anybody deserves it you deserve it
and 10 more behind it 100 because
like cox said using the background
helping us out with certain things that
nobody would say
you know nobody would do that yeah you
know and i
do appreciate everything that you do so
when you was on the show today
i was like yes you know
and i can't wait to get to germany and
go to gamescom and maybe we can be like
sardines
[Laughter]
together up in that place but um you
guys can catch me on dolph castlex
fridays at 9 00 pm
rich people talk about statues that uh
we definitely don't need to get but
love to have uh also uh you can catch me
on live unboxings on saturdays on dolph
castles x
uh statues is going up i was just doing
so much unboxings because i changed my
statue stuff around
i went away from sideshow and i'm
completely xm
um and that's where it is so i'm selling
a lot of statues
so oh somebody asked me where do i get
all this money from king
how do you have all this money to buy
statues well if
i'm selling a statue that money goes to
buy a statue i'm not
selling a statue because i need the
money i'm just changing my
uh collectibles around you're
reinvesting and reinvesting in
that's it yeah these stuff is you know
valuable collectibles that i enjoy to
have around me because it shows your
hard work is paying off
at some point in time in your life you
like you said you have to smell your
roses when you get a chance you have to
put out that stuff you can't always go
to work
you can't always just play either you
have to balance it out
and you have to show that you've done
something you have to reward yourself
please don't
just go through life just working and
rat holding your money and
not doing anything you have to get this
energy out i've noticed energy
on my timeline people are hating
on a particular platform either it's
playstation
or it's xbox i joke around a lot about
playstation who
have one upstairs games you cannot tell
me when these triple a party games come
out i don't support i purchase i buy i
play
in fact i just choose to play on xbox i
don't care but
it's about having joy in your life video
games bring you joy don't lock off your
joy talking about it's a piece of
plastic
you don't want to go to this place or
that place that's why it didn't make any
sense for me when somebody said they
is an epic store in the steam store you
just click and download and just play
so i respect eric thank you so much for
showing up i know it's a little bit
long-winded but i love you brother
and i'm much more successful yeah by the
same day and i'll
find out same thing yeah man again
tremendous um like i said it's always a
treat you know to get them
i know his schedule is completely man
does everything he is completely busy
but i
always honor when he takes the time to
do it and um yeah man another
inspiration for me that you've done
is that uh you know we talked about the
shows we talked about the e3s but one
thing i'm super proud of i always was uh
used to do like a video blog series on
your tgs tokyo game show experience
and that is a dream for me like so when
the pandemic whatever
that's something i also want the lords
to be a part of and i will be leaning on
you
for advice and where you even had like a
whole thing of like where you stayed and
just what to do and it's so cool so um
yeah man love your journey love to see
you keep progressing and yeah man look
again my success
as you've been killing it man you've
been really doing your thing and video
games you know your man lord of iron got
a rap
you know what i'm saying so you need you
know highlight your boy so we can get
the workout in that's that's what up
that's what talk to me bro like video
i'm about some video games
[Laughter]
honestly you know i i stand by as well i
i stand by what i said at the beginning
like i
really enjoy being on the podcast i like
what you guys are doing and i just see
you guys grow as well seeing from like
the first episode that i was on like
seeing
where you guys are now as well like it's
it's crazy to like see just so i see
the journey everything so yeah you guys
keep smashing as well like it's i'm a
strong believer that like
good people succeed doing good stuff
that's all it is that's what it is
it's not it's not a numbers game it's
not about that it's just about good
people doing good stuff
if you're a good person then preach
blessings blessings i absolutely get the
super chats over there we
officially got to close it out we got
108 dragons tv with the five dollar
super chat
invest in yourself and believe in
yourself they will recognize and follow
real brothers do real things work hard
play harder
preach you already know ekeezy when it's
ilp in the uk yeah we're working on that
like i said once the world gets better
yo new giveaways is out right now check
that out man again go to ireland podcast
twitter account
we've got that resident evil you know
what i'm saying so you want to get that
village
you know what i'm saying make sure you
sign up get it get as much entry as you
can
and um also mass effect trilogy y'all so
check that out the links are up on
iop's twitter account and again check
that poll on lawyergaming.net
make sure you make your void heard
everybody enjoy your sunday that's all i
got
we are out of here valentine's day y'all
[Music]
hmm
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye